before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys a
like really helps with the algorithm so
make sure you like the video on your way
in while you're at it sign up for our
memberships for our exclusive
behind-the-scenes content
okay so today we have a lovely panel so
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age where you're from and your
relationship status
hi i'm jessica i'm from
southern california i am 28 years old
and my relationship status is single
hi there my name is taylini i'm from the
uk
and my relationship's single
yeah
yeah um i'm peace over
from southeast london uk
uh single
so today the
the topic is
what is a high value woman
so to start do you guys know what the
definition of a high value man is
um
i understand what the definition of what
a high value man is from like
what kevin and kevin samuels have said
in the past which is like a man
or roller tomorrow where he says uh
frame game and what's the third one
no that's not a high value man that's
that's the things you can do to improve
your sexual market value
money money muscles frame game yeah uh
money muscles frame game and i think
that does go kind of go into like a high
value because if you've got if you've
got money and you've got
freight
and you've got
[Music]
yeah so the official um definition that
like this is what kevin samuels came up
with um you have to make 10k per month
and you have to have made it for three
to five years
that's the standard definition oh that's
the thing he he wrote he wrote it out in
like a stream yeah okay so but you're
close you're close um so other men must
accept you as high value so you can't be
a high value man if you just have money
yeah um
do you have to have a network of high
value men and you have to have a
linkedin visibility
level and you must be useful to others
in the group
yeah
i would agree with that
i would agree with that because if
you're not useful you're useless as a
man
yeah i mean if you're not useful
so on that token is there such thing as
a high value woman
that's a high value woman i was like i
wouldn't i wouldn't be opposed to if
if we're going off those if we're going
off that guideline then it can be said
for the opposite gender i think i think
men and women are different but um
i think a higher value woman
doesn't necessarily can't necessarily
exist without a high value man by her
side i personally think what one one
because
because the things that were listed out
those are for that's what makes a man
valuable to a woman
but what makes a woman valuable to a man
are not those things that are listed out
why can't she be
because
because a high value man like if we're
being a high value man a guy with money
a guy with his things together he's
putting his life together he doesn't
care how much a woman makes no it's true
but i think i to be fair i think the
spectrum will be slightly different for
women because
things are going to be seen different as
a guy like guys do guys have a role in
society they've got to do certain things
that females have a certain role in
society and they're going to do certain
things so within their role whatever's
there
you get me whatever's there big thing
that's what's going to make them high
value like guys i'll if we go with just
the um broad spectrum of guys provider
xyz girls um the nurturing type so just
on the broad spectrum doesn't have to be
too dear but i would say within that
sector whatever brings a female up there
cool that's what makes them high value
and whatever set on the guy's side will
make them high value being the network
and net worth and 10 um thousand pounds
a month whatever that translates to in
the female side that's what made them
into a
a higher fairly woman in it i think
that's what it is what do you think jess
um going off of what you said how
women can't be
and
um
is essentially what a man sees could
what i'm thinking is like couldn't a
woman be high value by herself and be
considered high value because that
definition i mean in the maybe in the
echo chambers of women like she'll be
considered high value if she's got her
own business together if she's
independent if she's strong like you
know someone like
i don't even know who to oprah
i think personally i would give if i had
to give someone a
high value like a woman who's high value
i'll probably say lebron's james wife
yeah that's what i'll say lebron james's
wife she's probably a high value woman
do you know
women you think she could be a high
value woman over 30
no but like i think she's a high value
woman because of kind of like the antics
that she showed you you're never going
to see her
like half naked on the ground you're
never going to see her embarrass
lebron james on the internet you're
never going to see her do anything to
kind of like jeopardize the james name
kind of
so that's how that's what i would
consider like that makes her kind of
high value i agree with him saying that
i don't think i slightly don't think
that a female could be high value
without a guy because like
go ahead keep going yeah because it's
like
end of the day
if we talk about people like you said
oprah she got all the stuff and ordered
some achievements and qualifications and
we're basing it off
like the stuff that she's gotten would
be
somewhat towards like a a guy's thing
like she has all this um
money and all this network and network
and xyz and that's more on the guy's
person that like if guys look at her as
you're like yeah god like yeah she's
she's doing her thing yeah you know what
i'm saying like she's a billionaire like
they don't want to screw it exactly yeah
that's the thing like they're they're
full like on a on a in a guy's lens yeah
she's high value but that's not the type
of girls that we're gonna go for do you
get what i'm saying that therefore like
on the female spectrum i don't think
she'll be high value but on a on a male
spectrum she'll be high value i think
it's flipped i think on the female
stretch from she'll be high value i
don't think so because i think i should
not think so females look at money and
accomplishments as high value
oh god that's what i'm gonna say on a
guy i think women have an innate
understanding where we we know who's the
most like desired girl in our friend
group i think we we can break each other
all the time
and
i don't i think girls are capping when
they when they think their money adds
something
because men just aren't attracted to
that yeah i don't yeah i can't lie
that's a fact yeah some women don't
realize that that like those men don't
care if you get what i'm saying girls be
thinking oh cause i got big bucks and we
like oh yeah he's gonna think i'm this
nah that's not even how it goes so to go
off what you said about oprah and men
don't want to bang her or nothing
what about a woman
that is a billionaire that dudes want to
such as rihanna
would you not consider her a high-value
woman no she's for the streets
i would have watched three i don't know
see wouldn't matter
i'll definitely be yeah
too much too much top top g's have been
up in that i mean drake's been there
asaps there even some unknown saudi
arabia king yeah
but you gotta be real now you gotta be
you're that's just that i think that's a
personal thing i can't even lie to you
like because unless his wife rihanna i
don't know she's got a ute now as well
no the use in the picture i can't lie
unless that changes you won't have to
take care of it no no i hear that but
that's a whole different you're gonna
have to play a role regardless that
you're in the picture now like that's a
whole different dynamic on this
obviously you're getting twisted in real
life if rihanna said you'll come like
what what my mom right now i'm like
she's got bread at that moment i'm sorry
my birthday
at that moment in time people will learn
how to fly to her wings will pair the
back of their backs i'm telling you
but i don't know like if what you
wouldn't go with rihanna
like i wouldn't take her serious i
wouldn't be like yeah this is my wife
like because what that is
obviously hypothetically i would be like
like i would want to be with her and
whatnot like cause she's buff it's
rihanna did you get me but
in reality would would that be my future
wife and what not like come on we've got
also look at what men value we value
loyalty and respect
so therefore the loyalty aspects
rihanna's been with a bunch of guys and
you can tell you she's been faithful to
them but like what's going on in those
relationships that is is not leading
to
a long term her getting already
didn't she beat up chris brown like
wasn't that mutual it came out later
yeah yeah that was though yeah
with that being said like
you go through relationships or the end
of the day you're first related well
more or less your first relationship
isn't going to be the the first one that
goes you're going to have to go through
door number one door number two door
number three before you get to that all
right this is the final door this is the
house that i'm going in this is the keys
and xyz would you get what i'm saying
would you say that rihanna has dated men
that you would class as high value in
society
so my point is
if a woman's goal is to attain the
highest valuable man in society and
rihanna is running through the high
value men in society and not being able
to keep them what does it mean for you
all right i hear you going that far
i know what does it say about it but
then yeah exactly
i hear you on that part but to also flip
the coin it's like like i said your fur
you just cause you go through several
high value men if you put it down on
this planet on this planet um
um on the plane aboard men are still men
at the end of the day like you're gonna
go through one guy regardless the first
high value man might not be the the good
one whatever whatever compatibilities
that they might be do you understand
that you might have to go through
several high value guys before you find
your right high value guide you get what
i'm saying you're talking from a man's
perspective that's okay for a man to
think i'm gonna go through several women
yeah until i find my woman
it's not the same for a woman it's not
the same can you guys take an input on
that like if if
if what he's saying is correct
well i mean what do men value men value
purity that's why like when i when i
talk to men and by and large they say
they would prefer a girl with a lower
body count versus a higher body count
right if you guys are gonna wife or girl
would you rather she slept with zero
dudes or a hundred dudes
zero right right
and so when a girl gets to 30 like
that's something she doesn't have
anymore by and large and it's also men
are also attracted to fertility so 90 of
our eggs are gone by 30.
and if you survey men between the ages
of zero to 80 they all say the most
attractive a girl is is between the age
of 22 23 and 24.
sometimes lower sometimes a little too
low
and so
so how could rihanna be high value
if one she doesn't have the purity
component she doesn't have the fertility
component and she doesn't have the
loyalty component because she hasn't
been able to either keep a high value
gap or maybe she left all of them i
don't know but either way like she's
lacking in the loyalty too by what men
value
i know i hear it i hear it i hear it
yeah
yeah
i thought that that i think in this
society that we have right now there's
not that many examples of a high value
women and i think the high value woman
that's being pushed out is
this miss independent miss i've owned
all these businesses i've got a big
house but i'm lonely with a cat hence
why they don't exist yeah
do you know why as well it's because
like more more towards like this whole
generation and what's going on media
well not like everyone's pushing that
there's a more push towards females
being more masculine for some reason
and girls don't play like
there's a whole trend with girls not
playing their feminine roles in society
just due to evolution and as things have
progressed in um throughout time and now
that there's this whole big push about
girls being so independent not that i
think there's anything wrong with it
however there's a balance and i think
that the balance has been tipped over
where girls just think they can do
everything by themselves and they don't
need no guys so now it's like
you can't see you won't really see high
value women because they're all trying
to be like guys yeah they're trying to
yeah they got all the money and like i
said like oprah all this achievements
and whatnot but you're not being you're
not being a female fitting into the
feminine roles that you look um and
that's what's actually supposed to be
they're more fitting into masculine
roles and trying to do all of this stuff
have you guys ever dated a girl that has
a cookbook
right so like women don't they're not
traditional anymore women
yeah
and
yes do you have a cookbook no i don't
have a cookbook but i know how to cook
yeah but it's not the same you know what
i mean like like having it no a high
value of like our grandmothers had
cookbooks yeah where they would make up
their own recipes and stuff and i'm not
knocking it we all grew up in the west
but it's like we're it's just a
different breed of women these days i i
think if if they're hypothetically was a
high value woman do they even exist
anymore you're not in the world not in
the west
are there women that are like trained to
be housewives from the time they're 18
where they learn how to cook how to
clean and they're beautiful like that's
a dime a dozen i would say
yes and it's mainly from what i've seen
it's
not i won't say mainly but a big
majority are from inside the church from
what i've seen they
bring them up to be wives to be chosen
why are there so many single women
that's not not in my opinion anyway
sorry let me know let me not say let me
not say it on the general thing but in
my opinion i've been that's entirely
true because
church girls
or sometimes the worst yeah really be on
a whole like you'd be thinking angels no
they're playing on the devil side of
town like yo do you know what i think
it's especially in the uk yeah i think
it's a it's more of a like a culture
thing especially like an african culture
like the
maybe not no more
i don't think it happens no more but i
think like coming up in the 90s and like
early 2000s that's that was really
pushed to like the girls
know how to be wives and what not know
how to cook and stuff like that but i
think
like
once we once we passed kind of like the
millennium and going into the 2010s and
stuff like that that's when it kind of
died down and
the mothers of the family kind of
stopped putting this pressure of being
housewives i think it died before that
with the development of birth control
yeah i think maybe in the states because
i think in the 90s a lot of a lot of
africans came to the uk around the 90s
that's when a lot of a lot of people
migrated here so i think in the states
it started
i don't know the development of birth
control was worldwide it happened here
too in the 60s i don't
know maybe to the cabbage that's in like
the free loves yeah maybe maybe maybe
you've heard about the 60s like maybe
70s yeah
i think that was an american thing you
know
okay no yeah i think it was majority in
america yeah because in the 50s and 60s
here that's when like the windrush
community came over and that's the
caribbean people yeah yeah
there wasn't that many black people
around it so like the windrush community
came around in the 50s 60s and then the
african community kind of came in that
80s and 90s yeah it would just it would
just be interesting to look at divorce
stats i value women if there is a such
thing as high value women which i don't
think we hypothetically i would say it's
when divorce started to go up because
that's when you start to lose the
loyalty yeah that's true you know
that's actually true you know because
when the force comes up and then after
they've all had to be independent and
whatnot and then there's a lack of
marriage as well so they will have to be
independent and whatnot and then there's
a lack of marriage as well so there's
that that indicates there's a lack of
wives
so a high value woman has to be
married or be able to go
attain the highest value yeah because
that's like that's like saying okay
a high value man has to be wanted by a
lot of girls so if there was a broke bum
in his mother's basement that said all
the girls want me everyone would laugh
at him but if there's a single a single
woman that hasn't been able to keep a
high-value guy saying oh i love being
single
and and i could get a high value man but
she has no results to show for it
errors then she kind of looks crazy
because because you have to think about
it is kind of easy for girls to get guys
like you can just look beautiful and
then a guy would
pop up out of nowhere you don't know
where he's come from
you don't know what you know who sent
this for some i was awesome i think for
the majority of like i think how much
is like 50 that guys well my men swipe
right 50 of the time but just
what i would guess based on like the
things i've seen and like the
discussions i've had that women can get
a husband or a boyfriend like fairly
easily like totally easy but it's tough
to lock down the guys that women go for
and oftentimes girls are shooting out of
their league
because because if a guy's in the top 10
20 and he's he gets all this casual sex
good luck locking that man down yeah
that's the issue the girls want the
drakes mm-hmm they want the futures
you know but they want to tame down the
drakes and their futures yeah that's
what the child did
they wanted they don't want the traits
in the future they want that kind of
characteristic but they want to tame
them down
but then they don't like it anymore
exactly it's the whole beauty and the
beast concept like
the beauty kind of tamed down the beast
and
you know
what what if um
there was a woman
and she was a virgin she had all these
things that a high value man is looking
for
and essentially
she
is a high woman but doesn't like tell
him like oh i make this much money or i
make that much but she keeps at her so
is that i think he's blessed i think
i'll be blessed
i think
personally this is just me i think i'll
rather
i'd rather find out
that you do something then you tell me
that i'll rather for example i'd rather
come to your house and see that you've
got a lamborghini or like you're doing
well for yourself
but you're doing both i've got a little
and after if you meet a guy and you go
to his house and you find out he has a
really cool shoe collection
that's cool right i mean you're like oh
nice shoe collection but you're not
you're not you're not trying to screw
him more now yeah and that's the same
thing with men it's like nothing to them
so if a girl a girl being if we if we
determine that there is such thing as a
high value woman like the most desired
women
like money it doesn't add or subtract to
it it's just there yeah that's what i'm
saying if she doesn't not even saying
that it's a thing but she just doesn't
tell him and she's still since she has
these accolades and she doesn't mention
it to him because she just doesn't want
to or he doesn't want her to is she
considered a high value
woman or
just because she's with him yeah she's a
high value a high value man has to agree
that she's high value
yeah yeah
she can't she can't be a high value
woman unless a height
yes he has to come in
yeah no he has to pick if you commit
what do you mean by commit like as in
like he claims you as well
like
that's why that's why i gave the uh
example of lebron lebron james and his
wife he claims his wife online i don't
think it has to be marriage per se but
it has to be it has to be exclusive or
not exclusive enough where everybody
needs to know this is my bee yeah nobody
like you i think she has to have a ring
she is she has to have a room she has
so the reason why i think she has to
have a ring is because that is the
ultimate form of in the west i'll say no
not in the
what
i i think she needs to have a ring
because that's the ultimate form of
commitment to the highest level where a
man has chosen you committed all his
assets his being to you
and said
you are mine but now but with that being
said devil's advocate that being said
you can say are cool
um would a guy would a girl still be
high value she gets cheated on
yes yes yeah because that that's like
nothing
yeah she's good
if anything that that increases her
value to a high value man if she if
she's letting him exercise his options
like i think
remember we have to think about it
there's not a lot of rich guys out here
you know not actually he isn't you know
that you might think there is no there i
know there actually isn't a lot of rich
that i have had so i've heard the steps
and it doesn't add up yeah so when it's
like when when a girl meets
a guy that's rich
don't decide like
you're probably not gonna meet another
guy like that in the next hundred guys
that you see
don't understand i think people are
thinking like a guest oh sorry yeah so
it's like you have to take your chances
when it comes and if a rich guy looked
like he was talking about the drake
video i guarantee obviously that was a
video and it's entertainment but i
guarantee you if you wanted to do that
100
and girls will they'll be perfectly fine
perfectly fine with it if he walked up
to those women who'd like to sign here
he's not here
okay we're all married
yes
who else who else is
who else are you married to 20 other
girls no because first of all
that's too much estrogen there's too
much female drama in one situation now
now if
if he's like okay i want to marry
all 20 of y'all but you all have your
own place i would consider it i would
consider it like i have i don't have to
deal with nobody else and you come over
when you want to and you give me my oh
maybe
give me a week
that's how it is in muslim cultures
where they they have to be able to buy
each wife a house
let me know in the chat if i got it they
have to be asked to be equal if you buy
one yeah yeah
yeah if you want one buy one wife a
house you have to buy them so you would
actually would you prefer that or would
you prefer okay
option one guy you like him a lot like
think about most obsessed you've ever
been with a guy in your life
that dude but more okay okay you gotta
share him or
least obsessed you've ever run with a
guy in your life but you get to have him
to yourself
which one you pick in
there's more that comes with it no only
we're only talking about the two
feelings
what do they look like
think about you could think about the
least into a guy that you've been think
of who it was
we're going off on my picks nah i'll
pick the one i'm obsessed with
and that's the thing girls would rather
share an alpha than marry a beta yeah
yeah that's true i'll kill
foreign guys
like certain guys don't actually
understand because guys do struggle with
getting girls nowadays and they don't
understand that yo a girl will just
she'll have she'll share a alpha guy
before she even comes to you
and
and i think that's that's why red pill
is so important because guys just have
to realize
what kind of predicament that they're in
and i think once you realize the kind of
predicament that you're in and if you
feel like you're in a you're in a
terrible position that's your that's
your kind of like your cue to start you
know get get up and start doing
something about it
i think so i was thinking about
what if we were hypothetically going to
have a high value woman
what what i would put on on that list
hypothetically okay which i'm not even
sure they like i would argue they exist
but if i was going to i would say we
have to do a weight component where they
have to be under a certain weight yeah
no okay
i would say facially they have to be
maybe eight or higher under the age of
27.
okay
and
can't be me yeah you were close
i missed it by the way and and they have
to be
and the only way they
and they have to be married to a high
value man
because i just would have a hard time
thinking like could a woman be 55 in
high value
but her value goes down the older she
gets so that doesn't really make sense
to me yeah but i think the beauty of um
like being a wife kind of thing yeah
especially with us if you've got a
husband
like i think that kind of like
your beauty kind of it doesn't change to
him kind of yeah he might still come out
and be his husband goggles yeah yeah
yeah even though he might still go out
and like have sex with like some young
bird and whatnot and not care about him
but it's like
he'll he'll probably still love you like
and still remember how beautiful you
were when you don't work together and
whatnot so i don't think you know
65 70. yeah you'll probably look at me
yeah you're not as hot as you was when
you was 23 but you know that you're
still my wife kind of thing you know i
still love you you still gave me these
beautiful children yeah i know he could
still love her but i just don't think
she would be in the most desired
category by man no definitely not bad
man definitely not bad men and if we
were like because when i think of high
value man it has to be the most desired
category of man
so high value woman has to be the most
desired category of women well there has
to be like an age and looks component
see i've got a question right okay
once you say like someone's obtained the
highest valuable man at a certain age so
let's say she's 27 or like she's about
to finish her prime she's
found the guy he's 35 whatever they now
grow all together wouldn't she be
classed as high value still because she
she
she hit the goal that she needed to hit
and that was the pinnacle of where you
you could argue that i just but not but
not to society just to that person
possibly to him
but i just have a hard time thinking
like a girl that's 65 is going to be a
high value woman you could argue it i'm
not i post i'm not sold either way you
know what i mean i personally think like
as i said earlier i think like
one of the only options or one of the
only people that i can look at is lebron
james wife
like would who would be like a high
value woman what about michelle i really
love savannah you know over michelle
obama no she oh no come on you wouldn't
because she's
she's leading him
a high value woman stays out of the
spotlight
[Music]
you don't hear nothing about her would
you you don't hear nothing and that's
how i would want my wife to be that you
don't hear nothing you don't see her on
the net you don't see her with no girls
and no not guilt trip you don't see none
of that she's she's about her kids and
her man that's it would you consider
kobe's wife to be
to be honest yeah after i only only
really and truly i would maybe consider
it because i only really actually
started to get to know what she's about
after kobe passed
like like before then i didn't really
know who she was but this is the same
thing of what you're saying about
thingies um lebron james is like that's
the same um situation you didn't know
about because she was low he did what
she had to do and you for what i'm
saying and there you go lebron not
lebron i mean um kobe yeah once again
r.i.p but um kobe they've been uh one of
the best athletes there isn't it
so and i think i think that's what
categorized you as a higher value woman
because think because it's never about
money because think about i think it was
uh sarah that said it on a previous
episode like cristiano ronaldo picked up
a girl that was working at gucci in
retail i understand like she was getting
ten pound an hour you know pound an hour
yeah and he picked and he picked her up
and now she's the mother of his three
black children so it's like
this is one of the sorry are you done
all right there's one of the things as
well i think i don't feel like a lot of
females understand that in terms of what
guys think how valued women are like you
really don't have to be
like yeah you got to be doing something
but you really don't have to be so well
accomplished as guys are and so
competitive as guys in order to be
class or think that you're out of a high
value status
do you think a high value woman can be
an average looking girl
yeah yeah
how yeah would you because it's all like
so you you would say that looks aren't a
component
i think i think looks gets you in the
door
and i think and i think a lot of guys
will like will definitely date like and
or definitely take an average girl
seriously
they'll probably still smash their
high value men take average girls
seriously what average girls are they
dating i mean not ever having average
looking not average inside to be fair
wait that's what i mean average
like just face i was just gonna say like
you just said looks will get you in the
door if you ain't got looks how are you
getting through the door now you could
know people outside though you could
like no no no no you could no no let's
let's let's like you could just know
someone like and you could be friends
and after they just call and then we
time goes by if i'm not in the door i
can't get in the room what
no but i'm trying to say is that's like
you couldn't oh
yeah so you could know like um you could
they could just start off being friends
like people have gone into situations
where they started from being friends
and then
high value man sorry no yeah because
look
what's it called you could have a circle
not even a circle you could you name one
yeah name kind of name one example yeah
all right so now to be fair
average looking girl this is what i
wanted to say
an average looking girl married to a
high value man don't change the subject
name one
gonna be so honest yeah lebron james's
wife when they first got together
that was before that was before he
became a hot yeah he wasn't a high value
yeah like they met in high school but
now he's but now she's a high valued man
because of because he eventually grew up
to that status now but he didn't pick
her that's when he was a high value man
he didn't pick her so you're saying off
the jump yeah
she was probably hotter when she was
younger though yeah she he said she was
the prettiest girl at his high school
i probably when she was younger i'd
probably give her an eight i mean
so that's what that's what i'm saying
obviously maybe now she's not as pretty
as she was when she was younger but like
obviously like as men we know a woman's
mute beauty kind of like goes away we
know that you understand and i don't
think a man even a high value man i know
we're using lebron as an example but
even him i don't think when they get to
60 he's going to leave his wife because
she's not as pretty as she was when she
was 33 to get me like all 23 or whatever
but maybe you'll still bang her 23 year
old you never know did you get me you
maybe you still would but i don't think
you would leave yeah because she's not
pretty normal what about you what are
you gonna say um no i was just going to
go off what he said about lebron james
uh
there was something that came out the
other day and i don't know if it's true
or not i've always thought like oh look
i've never heard lebron james like cheat
on his wife or anything and the article
popped up
and it was talking about this female who
was like yeah he flew me out
i thought that as well
yeah
that's interesting but then he kind of
replied on the internet what are you
saying that he's all about his
wife obviously he didn't address her
personally or didn't but he was like oh
like kind of like indirectly you can be
all about your wife yeah yeah yeah no
one's gonna get questions lebron james
has never changed of course
i would never ever try to convince you
of that
that's what i'm saying and that's how
you know that she's kind of like that's
what i would consider her or his wife as
a high value woman because she doesn't
even make no noise about it it's not
like she's getting on the internet and
telling
so question do you think a girl can be
high value if she's not a virgin
i wouldn't yes
but it has to be on a it has to be on a
smaller side of the spectrum
it has to
i'm just curious would you consider a
girl high value
how many bodies is too many bodies
that's the man according to rolo tomasi
if you've got more than five then
you've lost it so so five or more yeah
okay what about you
all right
how many bodies is too high yeah a high
value
yeah no it's gotta be five or less
how go ahead
let's go in
i i can't answer this because i don't
think
high value women as a statement really
exists unless she's got a ring chosen
right but hypothetically yeah not
exactly but then
it's disingenuous because like oh it's
just a fun question
i like your idea of one
um
as a high value woman
yeah i'd say five is a fair number i
would say at what age though like oh
twenty twenty one i think i think he's
twenty seven
based off what pearl said she's 27.
she's probably got more than that yeah
i'll argue that that case actually it's
more so that high value is the idea that
you can secure a man and be in a
relationship
like so like if someone's having
long-term relationships maybe two three
years
by the time they're 27 if they started
dating at
let's say 18 they would have had three
bodies
and that in itself would be like a man
has seen you and he thought i need to
secure this
maybe it hasn't worked out but you've
shown
thank you of the results to show you the
results and those guys they have to be
high value
yeah but then you don't also think that
potentially that's also a red flag
because that means typically women end
relationships
so like then is she is she high value if
she keeps leaving
yeah
she's not that's right
because like wouldn't that if she got
three high value men she couldn't pick
one she liked yeah that's a that's her
would that be a lack of loyalty i don't
think i don't think i'm just sorry i
don't i don't actually feel strongly
about this either way i don't think
girls leave high-value men like that
like i don't think girls leave the
alphas like that it's a little bit
harder yeah i think it's hard to because
because a alpha guy will cheat on a girl
and she'll come back
there has to be something
lacking
either mentally or emotionally for them
to in my opinion for women to leave a
high value man because he's going to
provide for them security is not a
problem but if there is a lack
in those feminine traits that
we essentially
need from a man then she may not cheat
right away but i think mentally yeah
i think it's hypergamy though i think a
lot of girls that are eights nines and
tens are for the streets forever because
they just have so many high value men
interested in them they can't pick
interesting and they can't go down evil
sorry no no good they can't they can't
they can't go down in it because i've
had so many so if a girl's 22 right and
at 22 she really like she's eight nine
or ten that means about the time she's
22 she's getting guys with blue check
marks in her dms if she's if she's hot
enough right yeah and so she sleeps with
one at 22. dates him for two years let's
just say but then she thinks she can do
better and she keeps thinking she can do
better and maybe she does until one day
she can't do better and then she's for
the streets forever because women can't
go back down and be happy about it and
the women that do let's say kim
kardashian right
okay what
knowledge yeah they leave them
or or they have their husband by the
yeah and i mean sometimes sometimes like
it depends how like the girl has to see
the guy is better like it's not
necessarily income like i've heard i've
heard nicki minaj's husband is like very
masculine and holds frank that's just
something i've heard don't know if it's
true don't know anything about nicki
minaj don't quote me he's married yeah
she's married
yeah but it's like she went back to her
best friend
[Music]
from the island no no no he was riding a
bird apparently and then he come out and
then
when he's out she's come back to him
he wait say that again riding a bird he
was in prison
that's what the audience was no sorry my
bad he was in prison he had he had one
prison sentence he was inside jail and
whatnot youtube when he's come back out
she was saying i think they've gone back
together in it but they were old like
old school sweethearts type of thing
apparently that was the situation if i
remember correctly so yeah
but i think she was but he obviously i
think he come out making less than
less than her and whatnot but well who's
going to make more than nicki minaj yeah
no that means
yeah
yeah not to be fair would you consider
women athletes high value no
if they're chosen by a high value man
yes
so only if they're chosen by a high
value man
so essentially
i could be
a bum but super
good looking and get chosen by high
value man and then be considered high
value yeah exactly
exactly
that's the gift i think that's the gift
that was given to i think that's the
gift that was given to women in it
because obviously i think
this world is hard in it like the world
is hard and people struggle to
understand and i think i think god
favored women in a bit because it gave
them that gift of beauty a lot of women
are beautiful there's loads and loads of
beautiful women in the world do you
understand so it's like it almost gives
you an out obviously
guys you have to work for what you get
to understand you have to work for what
you get whatever you get you have to
work for it nothing's going to come easy
for you and once you've got that that's
when you deserve you know
you know you reap what you sold it so
you deserve whatever you sold women
women are born with value men must earn
their values yeah oh wow it's explained
so women when a woman's born she she is
the most valuable asset
like so so a girl can be 18 and get
multi-million dollar modeling contracts
she could she could do only fans make
millions like she is a valuable asset
beauty is currency that's why you see at
um political protest women always take
off their clothes because that's the
best way to get attention is a beautiful
woman
and men
there there's a large proportion of men
that are invisible under the age of like
25.
and but if they focus on money muscles
frame and game by the time they're 35
they can get girls left and right
like jeff bezos right yeah i mean that's
not i don't know what he's doing with
that one check but
yeah that's a perfect example because no
one is looking twice at jeff bezos when
he's 18. but you know now he's built up
to be a billionaire he's got he can
screw whoever he wants still ain't
looking at him he got money but
given him giving you 50 grand will be
let him get like 50p yeah
and it's like toilet paper but let's say
let's say hallie halle berry
you don't really hear about her she's
she's still pretty but she's not she's
not the guy girl that guys are lined up
for anymore nope yeah margot robbie
what's your favorite even um
steve harvey's daughter
i mean i know she's for the streets but
in terms of attention she gets so much
attention
but it goes away when you lose your
looks yeah and she's kind of she's kind
of announced herself that she's full of
streets when she kind of yeah
said no to michael b jordan didn't it
he kind of wanted to propose to her and
take her seriously which would have
elevated her to yeah high value one
do you understand but and and the other
thing is that a girl she's like she can
be 18 and marry a billionaire but like
no guy can do that no yeah no
and so i don't think a lot of times
girls we don't realize how much
how different we're treated because
we're young women yeah like you're
automatically like more people hold the
door for you more people are nicer to
you more like men give you attention
just because you're you know under the
age of 30.
do you think is different
across um
different ethnicities and races like how
um
i guess you see how men like view women
like is there like a superior type of
woman to like an inferior type of i
think hot is
i know lori harvey's for the streets but
she's beautiful they both get a ton of
attention
they're both stunning i don't think men
are i think you can drop you can drop
like laurie harvey anywhere in the world
and they'll think she's beautiful she
understands like don't think she's
beautiful but um
what what what's
the kind of difference is the culture
and what a culture would consider um
high value is she a wife do you
understand is she her wife like how does
she carry her how does she carry herself
from that that's what that's where it
differs isn't it yeah but it's like what
men are asking women to do isn't
necessarily hard fit feminine friendly
what women ask men to do is hard
six inches six figures six feet they
can't grow
they need surgery now and they're yeah
that's a lot of guys proud i don't think
a guy's probably can't do that well i i
say that like you can't just well people
be injecting their knees and whatnot and
installing um
plates inside their knees just so they
can grow but realistically i think most
guys proud wouldn't allow them to just
just get surgery just so they can grow
like most guys wallets wouldn't allow
them to grow if they had the option to
tell them
you can grow like two feet and it was
legit you think they're not taking it i
know certain man will but ah are you not
taking it oh yeah i think i think i
think it's the wallets bro i think it's
all even if i had to pee to it now i
wouldn't do it
would you would get the surgery
wait at a young age yeah now when they
stretch your bones
hey look you think that's worth it i
play basketball
i could have used a couple three inches
no no no
no
no
there's gotta be side effects from that
so probably
yeah
who matters it doesn't matter if you
can't play because you're injured
because they stretched your bones
if you had the money for it and
everything
and your
ideal woman came up to you and was like
yo i want to be with you but only way i
will be with you
if you get this surgery it's not a deal
there's no way you can be ideal and be
cool with everything else about me
besides my height that means you have an
acceptance for who i am like i can't lie
like what so in order in order to beg
you i need to now install something else
inside my knees allow it that's like
that's like a dude saying i won't marry
you until you get a boob job yeah what's
not yeah
you doing that oh no
but the reason why i feel like it is
like to do with money is because
obviously guys are getting hair
transplants now and i know some of them
are leaves and all that yeah i don't
know about the weave bit but i know some
guys are actually like getting their
hairline tatted yeah um not not actually
actually a surgeon in it so the castle
would grow naturally in it
so yeah from turkey so it's like
so is that i think if the money was
there some people some people will take
certain surgeries maybe not put plates
in your knees so you can be taller but
there'll be certain surgeries that men
would do if they had the money for is
that
so you said you've never seen a man get
like a a head piece like put on like if
they're bald and they get like a piece
no no i'm talking about actual surgery
where you know they're so they can get
regrowth yeah yeah i know what you're
talking about but um
do you think that
one of the two is uh
i guess you say more masculine than the
other one if like you're balding you get
the surgery yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or
you get like
uh
the hairpin oh the hairpiece the wig i
think they're both the same no no i
don't think so do you know why because
the wig piece
you're now your dillian deli and more
towards the female side of the tower
like because girls are known for the wig
pieces now if you're doing the the the
plants yeah the um transplants you're
getting um what a hair molecule whatever
follicle from your neck or your back and
it's just getting transferred to the
dome like that one you can you can kind
of get away with it because it's still
somewhat kind of natural it's from you
and your body but from time you're
you're getting wigs and your end of the
day long hard shifts
you get what i'm saying like
that's a whole net now like yo like
what's that that's a whole new thing i
have a question for you okay
if you find out a guy has had the hair
transplant surgery you know i'm talking
about from the back does it make you
look at them a little different
it would make me
think more into the future okay like
when did you start balding what is that
what are the odds are if i have a center
he's going to be you're 28 you could be
dating like a 40 something year old you
know if yeah if he
didn't start bald until say like
40
whatever
like late age i'd be like okay that's
fine i can understand you getting
transplants and put it back in but if he
has the hair piece
i don't know i don't know why but when i
find out like a guy has that i'd rather
just not know because it just hits
different
i don't know i can't i can understand
why i can understand why i don't know
why
it just does it's the same thing i just
think like
as a man you've kind of seen a
beauty feature that you feel um
i don't know what's the word uh when you
feel insecure insecure about yeah and
you've found a fix for it yeah well some
of them are permanent some of them are
temporary but at the end of the day you
found a fix for it and that can be seen
as a feminine trait
no i don't i don't disagree with what
you're saying ish that's it that's like
you just described it that's it
because because it's like i feel like a
masculine thing is just not just
not too caring
when you find out a guy like got surgery
to improve his looks like that's
feminine
and i'm not
i it looks better so part of me is
like
because part of me is like a lot of guys
do look better with the hair transplant
surgery yeah but at the same time what i
find out like it doesn't hit the same
no but
like i don't disagree with what you're
saying me personally just [ __ ] it out
like if your thing's receding what not
[ __ ] out is what it is like like just
your genetics god made that that's what
it is that's your genetics you gotta
live with it like and just own it like
more time if you own it then you can
turn it around and make it your own
thing and you can create your own energy
and people might mess with you because
of that lie it might even make you
better if you do it the right way what
but if you choose to get it i think it's
like
people are getting away with it so i
reckon like there's because look if tory
lanez comes up to you right now goes out
to be like are you not going to go out
would you go out with tory lanez have
you got our toy lanes
who's do i know who that is that's
shot megan he's
shout out 6'5
i like five six i was like five six
sorry like you wouldn't go out lanes not
if you wouldn't guarantori lanes now he
seems like a fun time maybe you get what
i'm saying but he's got a transplant
he's done the whole shebang but he does
the difference
these girls that wouldn't or would have
gone out with tory lanez would have gone
out with him before the chance yeah
regardless it wouldn't have mattered his
money his status
is
and also with the boldness thing that he
was also considering i heard that
boldness more times comes from the
females genes and not from the guys
genes so
yeah so if your son ends up being bold
that's morally due to someone in your
family nope it ain't gonna happen so you
know what i'm saying there'll be more on
the women's side that's all it ain't on
the ground i think guys if you're
bolding the best way to like flip it is
a drag or a beard yeah grow beard or get
bowlers yeah
if you can't grow facial hair just get
bowl or go to the gym
i'm going to read super chats real quick
guys
we have a new movement on the chat or in
our lives get issue camera yes hashtag
you guys yeah yes sir you guys here ish
in the background come on we're here we
want to get him on camera do you guys
want to know what ish looks like he
could look like anything what do you
think ish looks like let me know in the
chat what do i look like guys
um but i am going to read the super chat
so all of these are going towards the
camera we are trying to to get the most
money by the end of june so we can get
him the camera by the end of july
because youtube pays you out a month
later
okay so
see green 626 what if a man was big got
small and had surgery to change his skin
that wouldn't bother me actually
if a man was big he got small and had
surgery to change his skin because i
feel like that's more of like a medical
condition
yeah
because yeah
okay um anthony johnson just a super
chat no message i appreciate you
appreciate it um john smith ish is going
to do the bones for stretching surgery
ish why do you want to look like a t-rex
they don't stretch your arms my man
wait hold up a minute no no that's fair
um my arms man is six two all right so
he's after yeah so like i've i've got
like six inches missing okay from my
height did they think you were going to
be taller when you were a kid no yeah
they did yeah
yeah it's just five five
yeah he just broke five foot this year
shout out to all my shortlands we
appreciate you
get a camera we'll show you
um hot is fire but humans will always
have in-group preference
um
jordan cunning um high-value man is is
the biblical six six six over six feet
over six figures
and over six years in the gym ryan
reynolds high value woman with a body
count over three by 28 years old doesn't
exist by the fourth guy she'll most
likely be too attached or too much hoe
and baggage show morals this double
standard sucks but it is relevant
sentience a good loyal chase virtuous
woman will make a man better trying to
finish my train of thought
actually i'm going to read that his
sentience has two super chats i'm going
to do this okay high value woman is who
follows and supports her husband not
because of her bag but she understands
that by his success she wins also knows
to avoid attention because attention can
quickly turn to unwanted in the
spotlight she values family overall high
value man can not exist without his
peers crowning him thus women can't be
high value without a man accepting her
but high value men should vet her
properly for she is the most represented
most representative of his brand aside
from himself a good loyal chaste
virtuous woman will make a man
a good loyal chase virtuous woman will
make a man better because a man has to
become high value first
ish before getting a camera get reading
lessons
appreciate you sentience
i i'm not showing everyone everyone
else's reaction we can hold that
get it get it here we go
okay a high value woman has values over
two over two bodies she is no longer a
high value woman of which a rich woman
is just that personal opinion
mustafi's shoelaces the only way to be a
high value woman and not a virgin is if
your previous husband's cheated or dead
um zebra play so jess has some light
nice legs swirl question mark
you trying to swirl maybe maybe
okay marco beck jordan keeping it going
with this podcast piece from norway um
sit and talk with you sit and talk with
cf for pearl and jess who is your
celebrity crush you think we got the
same one
go ahead okay let's see three two one
and say it you ready oh no
you ready can't do that do it on one i'm
trying to think okay get one in your
head
come on i don't have one come on pick
one
one celebrity you gotta have one one
celebrity you find attractive yeah i'll
i'll pick one i can't think of his name
but i'll say his actor name okay okay
three two one jesse williams
okay
yeah there we go jason
jesse williams is a good one yeah
okay are you switching you switching
jesse
that man who's aquaman i don't know who
that is
um
with the game of thrones that's it wait
what is his name look it up jason
and he's better looking than jesse
williams he's
all right guys no way no
run okay
okay i'm digital swag um 10 super chat
not even a message thank you so much
appreciate it um abe dammicks um pearl
can we get married next year um benjamin
wheeler a lot of guys value cooperation
and a partner partner but this isn't
discussed in the mainstream thoughts
pearl and jess you both look amazing
today thank you okay john smith pearl
have you considered responding to
patrice o'neill on women kind of proto
red pill figure and phenomenal comedian
who saved my life at some point we are
going to react to him we just haven't
gotten to it yet but we will react to
patrice o'neill um
david
yoko um heyo from ireland i've been
binge listening to your videos while
working out at the gym keep up the good
work okay let me refresh it real quick
and make sure how many years you've been
at the gym has it been six years
okay we got a couple more super chats um
michael what end what kind of camera
what kind dish
magic dropbox blackberry camera
now we were looking at a sony um a73 a
sony a7 iii so um is that the same one
we got last time yeah
we'll see like
me and people are going to have
conversations but like the fund is there
um people have been committing to it so
just keep pouring in guys we appreciate
them yeah that how clear do you want
ish's face to be
dragon stallion one zero zero one ish is
the ish the oompa loompa
i nearly touched the door handle the
other day i was quite proud of myself
yeah almost not quite though
i had to help him
i had to pick him up
yes he's a car seat and like a stick too
yeah
mack um please note this amount is not
for ish's camera but instead getting
just an easier to remember instagram
handle
sorry
it's simple
it's not i told you to change that
months ago what's your handle
[Laughter]
okay so a question how old is a girl too
old to be high value
if she's single it depends yeah if she's
saying if she's single um
i think if you've gone over the age of
34
do you know what because obviously
nowadays girls are looking a bit younger
you have to give it to them like oh hey
don't be like don't don't look younger
but you know they'll say their age and
it's like oh i didn't even know you was
that old
wait hold on i gotta interrupt this we
got a 500 super chat
from michael wood i'm sorry i had to do
that i'm sorry michael thank you so much
that is one of the highest super chats
we've ever got on these shows
that's a good look yeah it's your camera
yo save that's the same guy from last
time
okay i'm sorry keep going no yeah
yeah the age thing but don't you think
when you hear the age it kind of changes
though
be real when you hear the age it changes
it changes on what you how you want like
you know how you view it because
obviously if you want kids if you're a
guy exactly it will change it will
definitely so that's why i say
so
yeah i think if you're over i mean
yeah 30 33
yeah around that age
so it's that it's like that you've got
there it
is funny that's interesting because i
would think it's like 27 28 over
for me
it doesn't mean you're forever alone
with these dads
hypothetically gonna do high value women
that's a small percentage it's like if i
went up to guys and said you're not a
high value man i'm not insulting you i'm
just saying you're not in the five top
five percent ten percent of that
you know what i mean
i mean and then if you're a girl and
like you're not in a relationship
or with a high value man by like 25 or
26 like
or you haven't been able to keep a
relationship then i think
there's more that you have to do with
yourself like in terms of revaluation
that's what i would think like 25 26 is
like like because i i would think high
value women get swooped up immediately
because they would because they want
family and children
i think it depends on what the woman
prioritizes as well yeah guys we also
need to ensure that we're not getting
mixed up between high-value women and
the average woman because yeah it feels
like
in this conversation we're referring to
high-value women but we're also equating
what average women are lacking but but
the thing is yeah i think
an average woman an average woman can
turn into a high-value woman depend on
depending on how she behaves yes it
depends
she's attractive and if she's
attracted yeah
she can be average like as i said
cristiano ronaldo's woman was getting 10
pound an hour like and she's got she got
lifted right but she was probably still
above average in terms of the attention
she always got from that's probably
that's probably yeah that's probably
true
because she is beautiful yeah like if
you put her in a room like full of 10
women she's probably in the top 10
percent and looks yeah and that's true
and like i said earlier ish
asking them
if i was a bum but still looked like
something could i still get a high
volume in and everyone's like yes and
she's like
i mean you have to have the femininity
component so it's gonna be a feminine
bum yeah like it has to be a a girl that
maybe she wasn't raised with with money
but someone taught her how to be a wife
and that's something that i see a lot of
girls a lot of girls lacking today is
like a lot of women grew up in
single-parent homes with mothers that
weren't wives and so they were never
taught how to be a wife what does it
take to be
a wife or like the treats i mean someone
has to pick you
one so a lot of a lot of single mothers
are they were never picked
and two you have to know how to cater to
a man
and make a van feel like a man and i
just think that's something our
generation is lacking
that's interesting that you say
cater is because they were trying to
have you heard the song cater to you by
destiny's child
they were um
it was like either earlier this year or
last year
someone had came out and was like um
this song i
never catered to my man how was he going
blah blah blah but it's like when you
listen to the words
it's it's nothing bad as just a woman
being a woman her man's coming home from
um
work and she's like let me cater to you
like this is your day let me
take your shoes off let me brush your
hair and it's like why
when people are like we're canceling
that song like no
it makes me wonder like what would you
do for your man after he comes home from
work are you just going to be sitting
there
and
just
not doing anything well i think that
there's a like we have a generation of
women that
think they have an issue with submission
yeah
and i mean my my friend went viral
for just saying she submitted to her
husband joe rogan saw that clip that's
interesting
yeah yeah but it's crazy because all all
i did was like show me your ring what do
you do i love my husband i submit and i
became a better person
and
you know what's another thing people
were mad at me a couple months back was
my mom taught me that
you should always just say yes to your
husband like whenever he wants to sleep
with you because that's like your duty
as a wife and when i say sex is a duty
as a wife women freak out
and if you're not giving it to him you
can't be mad if you go somewhere else
you really can't you can't
be because you you like he laid the bed
out like you really um stopping a guy
from getting away really well she's
gonna go find it else um elsewhere
naturally just naturally you do that for
so long it's going to take a toll women
feel entitled to a man's protection and
provisioning but men aren't allowed to
feel entitled to sex why this is a
double standard lifestyle that we live
in and there's a whole generation and
there's a whole movement as well on fema
entitlement that's just crazy like it
doesn't make sense to the point because
it's it's been pushed out so much and
it's becoming normal like girls are they
must they want to get this off a guy
that's a guy that have a guy but when a
guy wants this to stand the third is oh
no he can't have this oh he's got a dude
i'm like yo like you females demand so
much but yet a guy can't and when he
does all of a sudden is oh you're you're
you're um a lame ass [ __ ] or you can
get you can get this for yourself and
this this that and the third i'm like
how does that make sense like
for some reason girls think they can
have their cake and eat it too and like
you said as well like there's um there
hasn't been a movement or there hasn't
been uh there's been a decline in in
submission and i'm telling you if you're
able yet a guy your guy has a long day
or whatever he's doing then he comes
home and you're out there nurturing him
and this is starting i'm telling you
he's going to do you proper not only
will he elevate you're going to elevate
with you that is it this is what i'm
trying to say nowadays people don't uh
what's it called play their role like
females don't play their role and as a
result males don't play the role and if
a guy tries to play the role and a girl
trying to play a different role it's not
compatible i think because i think it's
just the agenda that's being pushed and
i think the agenda that's actually being
pushed is the agenda of confusion yeah i
think a lot of people are confused a lot
of people don't really know what they
want don't really know what to do you
understand the guys are confused because
obviously they're not making enough
money to be getting the girls to
understand and and so so that means
they're not getting the girls that means
that there's lot there's a lot of
testosterone that's going around and
there's nothing in the mic yeah sorry
about that there's a lot of testosterone
that's going around and it's not being
released what jonathan and obviously the
girls are going around for the streets
right it understands which in the future
kind of damages their prospects of being
wives and stuff like that so feminism
lied to a generation of women yeah it
lied to them because they said like
chase the bag you don't need a man you
can do it all on your own
and now we have a generation of single
mothers and single childless women and
it's confusion yeah
and you know what as well yeah i don't
even mind if you want to go with r chase
the bag and do what you by all means do
that but know what comes with that
kettle of fish like you want to go chase
the bag this is what comes with chasing
a bag this is how you're going to be um
perceived and portrayed but it's like
females want to go out and chase the bag
and do all of this and be quite more
masculine because in a sense that's more
of a masculine role but yet want the
feminine benefit so the feminine
outcomes like
i've seen girls bad out of their league
because they're just freaking feminine
like they might not be the prettiest
girl in the room but they're so feminine
and submissive that like guys are lined
up to date 100
and they just really understand how to
cater to a man
do you think that can equate to
attractiveness in a man like say like
you said they know how to cater to them
submissive and you just know how to be a
woman but they're not as
good-looking
ask the guys i think yeah i think a guy
will
take a normal seven looking girl if
she's a five like average average yeah
let's say let's say she's a let's say
she's a highest average six six yeah
you say she's a high average yeah it
will take a normal average looking girl
over like a nine if that average girl
knows how to cater and be a wife hundred
if she knows how to be a wife and she
knows she knows that this girl's just
not she's not gonna embarrass my last
name she's not gonna embarrass me she's
not gonna embarrass my family jenna said
she's not gonna be all up in the
limelight and trying to take my shine
and whatnot i'm gonna look after her and
whatnot and she holds those values of
being a wife i think he'll take that
over the bad b that's on the street
anyway submission loyalty and respect
will give you three points well thank
you
but then the other thing too is like
i've talked to guys and they've said
they've never had a girl cooked on
breakfast
i'm like what
[Laughter]
but like not breakfast oh that's mad
it
[Laughter]
okay
cereal after the fact
what what kind of cereal is
some pineapple cereal
hey
i played the
i think one reason that women don't
uh
do that like cook breakfast for men it's
like a
it's a hesitation so i have a friend who
has cooked for umpteen dudes and me and
we and her friend group have told her
like you should make a cookbook because
you cook for so many dudes but
none of them have worked out but it's
like they're
it's when it comes to women like we
think like oh if we cook for them maybe
they'll stay maybe that'll be too much
maybe is she dating intentionally
like when you cook them for your hookups
that's the difference like i think i
think
like don't ever do anything for for
someone for tactical reasons do you
understand don't ever think oh yeah i'm
gonna start i'm gonna get with this guy
and i heard on the podcast they say away
to a man's uh heart is for his belly so
i'm gonna always cook for him blah blah
blah yeah it might work but be genuine
with it just be genuine with it if you
want to cook for him cook for him
jonathan cut for him does that obviously
know that yo that will give me extra
points yeah so on a day that you don't
want to do it know that that's going to
remove points from that you understand
he might he might he might just you know
cross man out
yeah so do it just do it genuinely and
just be yourself and whatnot if it's not
you if it's not something that you do
then you're not that you understand and
in the long run you're going to stop
doing it anyway because no one can ever
hold a front for so long well i think
that sometimes girls will do things for
the wrong guy and then their conclusion
is let's not do it for any guy exactly
and then it kind of shoots themselves in
the foot because okay they cooked and
liked it cleaned and did all this stuff
for the player right and okay he didn't
appreciate it because he he never wanted
he wasn't a husband yeah and so then
when she meets her actual husband she
doesn't do it for him and she's jaded
and so and he's thinking that's not a
wife yeah and even though maybe she was
a wife and she's doing it because she
she was hurt but now the next guy like
kevin samuels always used to say you
can't make men of the present pay for
mistakes of your past yeah that equates
to no future yeah
that one's a that's a troublesome one
sorry um even to continue what you said
like i think and what both of you guys
are saying as well is that you need to
start doing stuff out of genuineness
like you can't be so tactical with your
thing like you were saying because
you end up like you end up buying
yourself in the foot it's a matter of
you should just do it and not expect
anything and you shouldn't even when
even when you do meet the wrong guy you
shouldn't be like oh
i'm not gonna do it for no one else
because then it's like you're just
setting yourself up for failure at the
end of the day because you need to
understand these are qualities that guys
look just because one guy did you dirty
on it doesn't mean now the rest of the
guys are gonna do you dirty on it like
that's not how that's not how it works
yeah it comes with a game but the game
is the game at the end of the day you're
going to have some good days and you're
going to have some bad days but you stay
consistent eventually you're going to
meet a guy he's going to appreciate it
and then you'll move forward together
you just can't be so bitter about
everyone that fails because at the end
of the day you the moment you stop is
the moment you have to also realize you
stop um you have to stop um
um those expectations of trying to find
that that guy that you want or that
husband that can do you good if you're
not doing him good it's a give and take
situation you've got a gift to get back
well a lot of times women we don't take
l's very well men will take an l with a
girl and move on to the next one women
we take an l and we're talking about it
years later and we're still like saying
that ain't [ __ ] over and we don't take
no responsibility for picking the wrong
guys we take no responsibility it's
always on the men it's never our ability
to pick because i think this generation
of women have been cuddled so much and
have been said it's not your fault it's
his fault they've heard that so much
it's not your fault it's his fault and
it's like they've kind of they've kind
of
you know got themselves
they've kind of gassed themselves in the
source and and whatnot and it's like
and it's like they like they won't they
won't even see
a different way of seeing it because
it's been it's been gassed to them so
much there's no sense of
ownership yeah
and going off of what you said i saw a
comment earlier and i haven't heard or
seen this perspective whenever they talk
about body count i'm like
body count five when you guys are saying
five i'm like man that's low but
when
it was somebody and i think it was
someone who comments frequently someone
that's a member
sign up for a membership
they said that the reason why
body count matters is because
each person that a female has sex with
there's something that comes with it
either trauma either heartbreak or
whatever hurt and she's taking that to
each person and either it's gonna grow
decrease or something else is going to
attach to it and i never
i never really thought of it like that
because whenever
a woman gets to where she's like okay
i want to marry this person and they're
in agreement there's all this stuff from
all her bodies that she has and she's
taking into it if she never took the
time to heal and so i can
and it's another guy that she can't that
he can't live up to
yeah so people call it people call it
soul ties around here so it's like for
example if you've slept with five guys
already and the first guy was kind of
like he's always getting angry now then
to the next guy you're always like
you're getting angry more than you often
used to and then that guy was kind of
like a cry baby and you left him and now
you're you're an emotional wreck on top
of the emotional wreck that you are as a
woman you understand and the third guy
he's got this kind of trait and then
you've taken that into the next
relationship so that's why they call it
kind of soul ties and it's like you're
carrying those souls around you it's
like an energy exactly exactly energy
transfer yeah yeah
but feminism like lies to women because
they'll say your body count doesn't
matter and you're giving young and this
is what really bothers me about feminism
is i don't like lying to women you're
giving young impressionable women the
wrong information we're saying sleep
with whoever you want do whatever you
want and they might make decisions that
they can't not they can't take back and
it will damage their future
relationships i mean if a girl is a
virgin she has an 80 chance of being
being happily married after 10 years if
she sleeps with more than five people
that drops to 25
is that a stat yes
they surveyed women so that that's why
it's like around five six that you see a
really significant drop
and like the thing is feminism keeps
pushing things like slut-shaming where
men aren't allowed to have standards and
i just don't get with that why are we
allowed to ask all of these things of
men but men can't ask anything of us and
the things that men ask really aren't
that hard
it's it's don't sleep with too many guys
don't get too fat
and
be feminine and a wife it's things that
you can control but when you were right
when you have a generation of women that
just weren't raised by wives
actually that's the and that's the thing
in it you're not raised by our wives
because obviously they're not there's
not that many wives in the society
nowadays and
as they say only a man could teach a man
how to be a man
and i think it's the same for um wives
only your wife can teach a woman how to
be a wife
yeah i personally think kenny i think i
think if you're for the streets you
you're the only thing you can teach
another woman is how to be for the
streets jonathan maybe you can look back
and be like these are the mistakes that
i did
maybe
but as we say women don't really like
taking accountability
for the things that they do and it's
hard for them to admit sit there and
admit and be like i've done a mistake
this is not the way you should go about
it if you want to be a wife or whatever
and the thing is like
what i've when i've talked to guys like
one-on-one about this stuff where they
say like a lot of time guys are willing
to forgive a lot but it's if you're
coming they still come at men at a from
a place of i'm better than you
instead of when they should be like
thanking them for like taking them
you know what i mean but like like
they'll have a kid and still feel like
they're better than the man yeah but and
like men like honestly there's a lot of
guys that volunteer to be step dads like
to be honest i'm not i wouldn't
recommend it but it happened it's
definitely the opportunity yeah
yeah but guys are willing to accept a
lot if you're coming in like humbly but
girls still come in with this entitled
ass attitude when you got
two kids from two different dads like
what you should be begging that man that
makes no sense you should be cooking
everything cleaning everything going off
of what you said about how a wife can
teach
a
woman how to be a wife and a man can
teach a man how to be a man
would
can a
man that has all these other has all the
accolades for a high value man but was
raised by
a
a woman like a single mother can he
still be considered high value
it depends on how much he
invests in time in getting counsel so
whether if he's reading or understanding
how to be a better man or if he's
seeking counsel from like the men in his
community it's very difficult for a
woman to play both roles and show a man
how to be masculine
as well as feminine yeah it's what the
man does
himself
is he being is he going on self like
growth is he doing self development
i think men compete amongst men
like you have to compete against men you
have to learn amongst men
like whether it's it's in anything
whether it's in music like
like you're you're with your boys you
are rapping to each other you're doing
cyphers you get me you get better
like if you're hearing your boy doing
music you get better do you understand
if you want to become a better gentleman
you have to be around like you know more
gentlemen and more men that you look up
to and whatnot and be around those kind
of circles that's why you could like yes
your mum will teach you how to maybe
show love to a woman and how a woman
wants to be loved and whatnot and she
can give you that that kind of
information but she can't teach you how
to be a man
you understand you can never teach her
how to be a man she can teach you like
the nurturing side and what it means to
love someone and what it means to like
love your kids and love your daughters
and love your woman maybe she can teach
you that but she cannot teach her to be
actual man well and and the thing is i
think some girls that didn't have why
like wives as mothers in the pictures
can learn it but they need to learn from
a way
so maybe they seek that counsel from
somewhere else
but it's always going to be a factor for
them but like the problem is we don't
identify what the problems are as women
because we're lied to all the time so
you can't fix up you can't find a
solution if you don't know the problem
and and that's like self-reflection but
women just lack that nowadays so i like
i can't even lie that's a lot like they
really do not i hope females see this
and be like all right cool but to what
i've seen like most females
who either put themselves in a bad
situation or be in a bad situation and
whatnot and find somehow
to flip the script like they didn't they
didn't put themselves there like it was
all the guy's fault and i'm like how do
you not how can you not take yourself
out or not even just take yourself out
how can you not just realize like all
right
i had involvement you might not even
necessarily i'm never gonna say you're
the whole problem but you have a foot in
the problem like there was even funny
enough there was one clip that i was um
um watching today earlier on today about
some woman who got her stuff like she
must have been in one sugar daddy
relationship on youtube and then after
um things went sour and he must have
called um the police on her got some
charges of felonies on her and now she
had to take out all the stuff so that
she can pay for the um
pay for this case now that she has gone
back and forth for the guy and she
didn't take accountability in the sense
that she got involved with the sugar
daddy and she went into the situation
thinking that this sugar that he was her
boyfriend and now she's like oh this is
why i don't get into a sugar daddy
relationship well but she didn't even
say sugar daddy she said boyfriend so
now she's already flipped the script in
her mind like oh boy um this type of guy
is um bad but she
in her head the the whole situation had
changed so now it's a it's a thing where
she's trying to downplay the guy whereas
it's like no you got yourself into a
sugar daddy relationship play your part
and play your role you need to
understand you can't get too close or
too um
invested in such relationships um
because it's
he's paying for your time you're not
you're not the only reason why you're
there is because he's paying for you
minus that you have no value whatever
whatever now can't no go ahead oh so
once once all the deaths once all that's
disregarded like she
she's she has no value in there but
she's still forced oh she had value oh
you're supposed to he um he's supposed
to do this for me dude definitely not
like you're getting paid for it once
once he decides oh i don't want to pay
for it that's it like you gotta go back
and do whatever you're doing but she's
out here complaining like why is he
doing this to me
that goes into accountability as well
though yeah she didn't take none of it
well i genuinely feel like every
situation is your own fault like and
this is thing i've been cheated on
before but it was literally my own fault
i picked him what the [ __ ] like how am i
how are you going to blame someone else
when you pick him
so and then and then you can do what you
want with that information you can stay
or you can leave yeah but the point is
if you if you understand the problem
which if it's if it's you then you can
work on fixing it but if we don't know
what the problem is then we can't fix it
but the thing is when you tell men what
the problem is like their brain is just
like their brains are just different
like they they're they our brains are
wired to like
yeah so that there's no problem no more
thank you yeah
that's it there's no other goal like we
want to fix that problem so there's no
problem no more that's why more time if
a guy is asking um if a guy's seeing
that his girl's a bit moody he asks oh
you're all right and she'll be like oh
i'm fine it kind of kind of pisses us
off because i can see that you're not
fine
so i know that there's a problem and i
want to fix that's what i'm asking and
when girls play mind games and kind of
run around the story and run around the
bush
it can get annoyed and that's why it can
get annoying and you know
that's why guys will hate we want to
find them
yeah
and i had a girl come on the show and
say that it pisses her off when guys ask
her if she's on her period you're on
that show yeah yeah and it's just like
he's trying to figure out what the
problem is yeah are we having an issue
or is it because you're on your period
and and it's like we can't even we're in
a society where men can't even help
can't even point out what the problem is
like fat shaming let's take that
if you know what the problem is you can
work to fix it like i've been
overweight and i wouldn't have lost 25
pounds if i didn't think oh
i kind of look fat to be honest
but the problem is men can never say
that there is a problem
yeah you know what there needs to be
more girls like you out here because so
many girls won't like all of this is
accountability and it's like
that's what as a guy like you said we
want to figure out the problem but in
order to figure out a problem we gotta
ask you like if something's wrong with
you and we don't know how else are we
going to know without asking you but
it's like we're not allowed to ask you
or not not to say this and that like
it's a like it's a taboo like why why
can't we ask you and then is either that
we can't ask you and you expect us to
know you put us completely in the dark
and still expect us to find out the
solution i sometimes think like it's a
game for the girls you know especially
when you look at on social media it's
almost like it's a game for them because
they make memes about it and it's like
there's a meme where you know uh you
approach that he says yeah you approach
a guy and um
he askes you out but you expect him to
know what you want and then you walk
away because he doesn't know what you
want and it's like
no that it's like it's almost like a
game for certain girls in it like and
they expect you to know in it i want to
read a comment that was just in the chat
um okay wait it just refreshed but i
took a picture in case this happened
okay um so the the title of this video
is baby mama's aren't high value
okay
and remember when we're talking about
high value like i wouldn't even call
myself high value that's a very small
percentage of women i would say
so i don't think it's an insult to even
call a man that like he's not high value
yeah even for men that there's a very
small percentage of that but this is
this is the girl's comment baby mamas
aren't high value wouldn't that wouldn't
the men that made the baby mama also not
be high value it depends dudes need to
work on their insecurities women with
kids just remind men that they had a
life before them
say that last part again women with kids
just remind men that they had a life
before them so it's like she's shaming
men for having standards but this is the
thing in it this is the thing um we have
to look we have to understand that men
and women look at each other differently
yes you understand men and women look at
each other differently sexually in all
different types of ways a woman looks at
a man's
future
yeah that is he is he ambitious is he is
he gonna do what is he gonna be have
money is he going to be able to give me
security give my children security
that's all future things do you
understand a man will look at a woman's
past to understand how much body count
does she have how um is she was she a
whole was she for the streets do you
understand what kind of history does she
have so we look at it we look at things
differently so when when um when we say
like a baby mother do you understand
that's her past she's that's her past
her past has already been tainted to
understand it's been tainted you
couldn't control yourself because every
person that gets born that is your
choice as a woman because you have a
choice to give birth to that person
why weren't you married is that if
you're pregnant why didn't you get
married why didn't you get married to
that person that got you pregnant and if
he couldn't marry you that means you
wasn't high value enough but on the
other end women look at men that have
children it's a form of pre-selection
we're attracted to it
and it that's not it's a double standard
but you can't change how people view
each other
like women want men that can get other
women it's
i don't know how to explain it but when
women see
and it could be any type of children
because i worked at a camp for years
and
seeing a man be able to work with kids
no matter if there's little kids old
kids it's just like a oh my gosh she's
so great with kids and then you start
thinking about like if we have kids
then he'll be great with them it's just
it's nothing that goes into the um the
whole like leader perk that women like
to see in men if is he a leader can he
lead to understand and obviously if he
can lead children and children like him
and it's like that he can probably be
able to lead me and my children and be
nice for my kids and that's what and
that's what the trait that women look at
and that's that's just the difference
isn't it so i do have a question for the
men
say you were talking about earlier how
um when you ask a woman and they play
games and whatnot what if is it
attractive if a woman
understands
how
how a man's like brain works and is able
to operate in that i think it will help
her i think it will help the women i
think it will definitely help you as a
woman if you understand the way men
think you understand that they're very
logical they're very straightforward
they're very black and white do you
understand is there a problem yes what's
the problem this is the problem what can
we do to fix this problem boom that's it
jonas down if like if you want to be
swaying like with your emotions yes
you're good
you're good now but 10 minutes two
seconds later you want to cry and you
want to scream and hit me like that's
too much that's too that's too much
confusion think about it if you want to
if you want to sell a product you should
know who you're selling to yeah yeah so
so you know you know what the buyer
wants
and then if you don't if you're not what
the buyer wants you try to change the
product to be more of what the buyer
wants yeah
i was gonna say it just gives you an as
a woman
it's not so much that if we find it
attractive but it gives you an upper
hand in the game
the moment you know what a man wants you
can operate like pearl said with the
buyer and seller you can operate in such
a way that you can
acclimatize yourself to put yourself in
a position to get
to do what you want with that man
because a lot of a lot of people will
say that i tell people what to do like i
don't i don't tell people what to do i
just tell them what the game is and how
men think
and it's like you can you can play it or
you cannot but if you know that you can
get a higher value man if you lose 20 30
pounds that's in your control
like a lot of a lot of things are in our
control
i think some people are just too lazy to
understand or know how to play their
game jonathan like some people are just
too lazy like and that's all it is
because
it's that when once you as a guy once
you understand okay cool
because the results are going to be
there for you you're even going to get
girls or you don't get kills you
understand and if you want to get girls
like but you don't want to chase girls
you have to understand what goes into
getting what how does how does a drake
get girls because i know he doesn't
chase no girl how does a future or chris
brown get girls you have to and then you
have to actually be the act what does he
do other than chase girls he he's on his
game he's on his music he's on his work
he wants like he making sure that he's
doing things that that you know that
gives him things that you know and the
spoils of that is women well women women
someone commented women try to change
the buyer rather than change the product
yeah
yeah so yeah
that's that's it yeah hundred hundred
that's the third hundred now on the flip
side do you think
women should try not women but men
should try to
understand women more i think we
understand women more than women
understand themselves yeah i think
that's true
i think because like
women are undecisive like they don't
know they're confused like we've all
like established how confused um females
tend to be and it's like guys can see
what they initially want like you come
up with you come up are
and you want do you like this dress or
that dress and you're like um they say
they picked that one and like oh they
don't they they still don't know what
they just oh no i don't like that one
actually oh well why do you like they'll
make a whole fuss out of it and it's
like if you go off more time if you go
off what the guy said not only will you
have results you'll be able to move
forward but it's like
yeah girls are just
girls are so confused and i feel like
guys can see
their solutions
when it comes to problems and actually
because guys are problem
problem solvers and whatnot compared to
females so i i i low-key don't
i low-key don't feel like um guys need
to um
understand yeah yeah i think guys
understand girls because i think it's
like it's the pursuer and the one that's
being pursued do you understand
like
that for a lot like if you also hunter
has to know the gazelle exactly the lion
has to understand how the gazelle moves
the lion has to understand when the
gazelle is probably gonna go take a
drink like it has to understand when is
the right time for me to pounce yeah you
understand so so like so if you're if
you're a hunter you you have to you have
to study your prayer you have to you
know
analyze how your prayer moves and and
whatnot and know what they're into that
in terms of a woman if you're analyzing
know what they're into you know if a
girl if you think that she's the kind of
girl that likes to be taken out and
whatnot if you want to take a serious
calm find a wine and diner if you don't
want to take her serious you can still
do those same kind of things to get her
attention and whatnot like if women knew
what we wanted why are single childless
women over the age of 45 the least happy
i mean we're by our damn selves
like if we really knew what made us
happy like 50 of women over 30 are
single and childless and the number
and fit and
females are twice as likely to be on
antidepressants as men
seriously and antidepressants are rising
in the us mostly in women
and the number of americans who say they
have taken an antidepressant over the
past month rose by 65 between 1999 and
2014. wow wow what
that's
what did you guys consider a man
understanding
a woman to be
more feminine or
no no no no no he's a sweet talker
or is he just is it just playing
he's got game yeah he got game 100
it depends in what context
are you understanding female nature
or are you trying to understand what
women want
wait what do you mean by that so like i
i don't know how to phrase this but like
you'll find
for example
a beta male or simp may be catering to
what the woman wants
as opposed to understanding the game and
understanding what a woman needs that's
true
what women want
can be anything under the sun we don't
even know
oh i'll do this want this
okay exactly however if a man
understands what women need
it can be she can be telling you what
she wants you put in place what she
needs and she make should i either
conform or move on yeah but more time if
she wants to be there she'll conform and
it will be the right decision for what
you're trying to do it takes a lot of
understanding however it's
how you as a man need to move you need
to understand what women need as opposed
to what they necessarily want
yeah because that changes yeah
like haven't you ever heard girls say
that i like i kept telling him what i
wanted he wouldn't listen so i left
but
a lot of times when guys do what the
girl wants she leaves as well
and so men are just confused because we
say we want this this and this and then
they do it
and we walk all over them like isn't
there there's some
form of like comfort that i think as
women know that we have a guy that will
tell us no it's when we're acting crazy
because i feel like we know deep down
that we're crazy like on some level like
every girl at some point yeah at some
point because we're chemically different
every single day
so having it like and a guy doesn't have
to deal with that he doesn't have to
deal with our hormonal
hormonal cycle so it's nice to have a
guy that can just like make decisions
for you
and that you can trust with that and to
even um
double up i think it's a thing where
like with this whole feminist movement
like you got you got bear there's better
social there's a lot of social pressure
when it comes to feminism and then
you've got a lot of guys all trying to
conform to it and as a result it's just
it's just bred a lot of
beta type i'm beta type guys so it's
like oh now you get guys who are doing
what all these females are asking for
and it's like still
they like you said they walk all over
the mall they still end up leaving
because men will do the most for huge
people
men will do the most for coochie and you
know if they can't if they if they don't
have exactly if they don't have options
don't do the most if
like if a girl says oh yeah i like it
when a guy acts like a puppy around me
and woofs you know if he hasn't been
getting gucci for three years he's going
to woof bro
so but it's like
like he doesn't understand the game in
it yeah yeah
he doesn't understand the game but
that's that's the thing i always say
that
what are you laughing at no i was
thinking
he's gonna be like homegirl from coming
to america
[Laughter]
no but i always say if girls are saying
that men are trash and they don't like
the way that men are behaving like it's
on us because men will do whatever for
sex they'll do so if if they feel like
they have to be an [ __ ] to get sex
that's on us
because who are we sleeping with the
nice the guys that treat us right are
the [ __ ] yeah
and once again girls are the problem to
that like yeah you lot of bread you lot
say you want this and then go for the
opposite you don't say you want the nice
guys but go for the bad guys so that
therefore
guys are going to be bad so they can get
sex out of you or whatever but then you
get the nice guys and you don't want it
like but a lot of times the nice guys
are the guys that are too afraid to say
no which i don't think equates to nice i
think it equates to having no backbone
yeah yeah that's a difference yeah
yeah yeah that's a difference i can't
lie
and me a person i'll put the blame on
the guys for that one like think what's
it because uh and then it does obviously
in with with
with this whole thing it does you know
it does like kind of carve out different
sort of reactions from guys as well and
there will be that you know that
percentage of guys that are angry and
not pissed off that they haven't been
getting no options and they haven't been
and you know it comes out in like a
negative way and whatnot but that's why
that's why guys need to
be able to control their emotions and
know that yo you can't run by your
emotions like the way
females do and all of this i feel and i
feel this and i feel that and i feel
that needs to kind of go out of a man's
vocabulary and start thinking more
instead of feeling well and there is
something that
gives women the it when we feel like we
are
less emotional than a man like we're
supposed to be the emotional one so if i
feel like i have to tell you to like
chill
i'm like cooked exactly
because how do you guys feel on that how
do you guys feeling actually i don't i
don't want an emotionally available man
i want him to be unavailable i also want
him to hate women so he hates all women
but me
[Laughter]
like who wants to get and there's gonna
be times where like a guy sure he's
gonna cry at times but like there's
something about a guy that is strong
most of the time it only shows you his
weaknesses
that is that is something different than
a man who's just weak and shows it to
god damn everybody
i can
i can agree with that i reckon the only
time is like for me personally guys the
only time it's cool to cry in front of
your girls is if a family member died do
you understand that even then i'll say
just watch it a little bit don't don't
do too much not after you understand
like maybe when you're by yourself and
you're with your boys that's when you
can actually let it all out because your
boys won't judge you
do you understand but don't do it in
front of your woman or any woman that
you have to look after don't cry in
front of them and talk to them to
understand because if they look at you
from like a security standpoint if
you're crying bro it's long for you bro
if you do it all the time and then it's
a issue if you do all the time man just
won't do it at all no because i think if
you do it at all
i think if you do it at all
that's why i say even when your family
even if a family member is dead that's
car maybe a little off a little a little
quicker
together
i think by and large like less crying is
better i mean i think if you're gonna be
married to a girl for 50 years like
you're probably going to cry in front of
her at some point marriage probably
isn't going to end
but
it's always better to be more stoic yeah
yeah strong because we want to feel like
we can come to you and lean on you
mm-hmm
be realistic i don't i don't really mess
with what you have to say entirely like
i don't believe
my personal opinion i don't believe that
a guy should be so
just out there bowling tears all of this
that i don't but
on a realistic sense there's gonna be
one two occasions that's gonna make
tears drop and it might make tears flood
but
there's only it has to happen only like
family members or your homeboy could
have died and it could have been a tight
home whether you've known since birth or
since but in front of her dog that's
exactly what it is like that bro like
you can cry like like let's say your
homeboy died yeah god forbid yeah your
homeboy died yeah and let's say for
example jess is your guilt yeah but
right now
right now right now you can tell me blah
blah blah but i wouldn't expect you to
cry because she's there
you need to hold it down well maybe
maybe when justin when jess and pearl
leave to go in the kitchen or whatever
but that's when we can have our and
that's when you can hey
i won't judge you bro do you understand
no i heard you're saying
bro in front of girls it's kind of
sticky i'm i'm i'm not the type to deal
with that i can't lie i'm not the type
to go out while in front of people
i can't like uh
built i've been built tough like that
but i'm thinking in the sense of yeah
just to play devil's advocate let's say
you're you're by yourself and it's like
oh you're balling and then after your
girl comes in and she's like what you
messed up i just uh i got it i got a
white those things
if i'm crying by myself and my girl
walks in with people i'm gonna say no
i'm cool but if i can't stop it gee i
can't stop it like if that's the
situation you and i dare remind you i
dare a woman or a man to try to tell me
otherwise i'm a next man or distance
down the front just kind of balling i
mean i think you're being realistic at
some point in a marriage
you're probably you're probably gonna
cry in front of her at some point but i
think their point is like when a girl
sees you crying she's less attracted to
you by and large it doesn't mean the
marriage is over the relationship's over
but by and large like there's study
after study and it's not fun like this
doesn't make us look good as women
but it shows that we are less attracted
to men after they cry i hate you but i
say would that be
um does that um take into account how
frequent the man cries like if he's on a
one-off times
then but that's that's what i was saying
earlier like you want to feel like like
a man is strong and you're the only one
that sees his soft side that's what i'm
trying to go off like only i'm gonna i'm
coming from the point only my woman will
get the opportunity to see my soft side
like on those one of occasions but more
time
is yeah like it is what is we keep it
pushing all right that's cool i'd rather
i'd rather come
obviously like whether death in the
family is kind of a sticky situation in
it there's not really much solution but
if he's that something to cry about yeah
i'll rather come to her with a solution
then come to her with problems
but my scenario wasn't i'm coming to my
woman with problems she's caught me
like you get what i'm saying like she's
caught me crying so in your situation
you've taken an l that's it just keep it
moving like that that's all you could
say
it's happened no like we can't stop that
there's nothing you can do but no one's
going to come to you and say you're less
of a man but we're just saying women
lose attraction statistically
when they see a man christ so it's one
of those things where yes there will be
times that you are vulnerable
if you can avoid yeah
yeah no yeah
i'm with you on that part there i'm
moving on that part there i'm just
saying in this in my scenarios just when
if she catches you crying like there's
what can you do about the situation that
is one of the i'm but i'm not the one to
i'm not an advocate for going to your
woman and crying that's a that's a yeah
that's our whole next flex that's going
going back to um
women understanding men more what if you
were crying and she came in and she's
like okay how can we fix this how would
you how would guys react to that would
it be like oh
yeah i've got elsa hey
look i i just need some time
i need you to
come out the room
i appreciate you i i appreciate you for
everything you do for me but right now
this ain't it yeah
would you leave
yeah i would leave i would i would give
him a space and i think at that moment
if it's something like that then i would
go and seek counsel from my
guys
and it's not because i don't feel
like
i don't want to share things with you
it's more so that
women are ill-equipped to understand
male problems exactly exactly and that's
nothing against women
but it's
what men go through on a daily basis is
something that
a woman may not understand or even be
able to comprehend because she's never
stepped in a man's shoes yeah you can
say that but you know and vice
um but the difference is as a man i'm
meant to be the stronghold in the family
and so if i am no longer the stronghold
because
i am now breaking down
situations
you may not see me as the man that i
once was hence losing attraction hence
possibly losing respect and
it's a caveat of things that can happen
not always
but this is biologically what could be
the case and you know what i would say
the opening up part comes into it like
if we use um
example like he's gone and spoken with
these guys right the opening up part
comes after he sorted out that situation
the situation is sorted now and like
it's over without that's when i can come
to you and be like yo babe basically
this is what happened i was in this blah
blah blah
but we're good now did you get me i
fixed it like i was in debt or whatever
but i've managed to make a hundred more
100 more thousand pounds so we're good
now do you understand so you're coming
to your girl with
solutions instead of coming to her with
problems because if you come to a
solution she can see that oh you're able
to get yourself out of a rough spot
you're you're a strong guy by yourself
you don't need her to get any and then
that in in return she'll can rely on you
more than that because the problems make
us more anxious
yeah like we get more emotional over the
problems than men
that's why men are better problem
solvers because they can just look at
things logically where we look at things
emotionally so if they're coming to us
for a problem like we might give them an
emotional solution which isn't the best
one
can i also say something like have
you guys ever been in in whatever tour
situation and a girl's just trying to
suggest something to you and it's just
one of the it's just one of the dumbest
things that a solution could be to
whatever the situation is like and no
offense to females but just to show the
spectrum even on to flip the script have
you girls also been in a situation where
a guy is coming on a logical standpoint
but i just said to you guys like what
it's like what the [ __ ] are you not
talking about like what was like no
that's not gonna work it's like that's
that's how i've been in a room full of
females and that has happened you get
what i'm saying like it's that's that's
literally how it is like certain there's
certain suggestions females have chucked
out there and i'm just like
yeah like it's not going to work and and
even at them about female having
emotional um decisions yeah reactions
and decisions is like
i've seen situations where females have
given out um a solution and a guy's gone
for that and after it didn't work out
they've come back didn't work and then
after the theme was like oh but why did
you do it i'm like you said it i'm like
what am i like how does how does that
make sense because you said it all in
the heap of your emotion and that
emotion led to a ripple effect and then
now the guy has to still deal with that
situation but as end of the day is him
going off a
female um a female's um standpoint and
as a result it it didn't have the the
necessary um outcome that should have
happened if he had done it by himself or
gone with his guys because
guys just for guys situations guys have
more logical and it's
more logical um solutions and it has
more of a long term
um men and women live two complete
different realities yeah
like we literally walk through the world
with two complete complete different
realities
a man's reality if a woman
for like a week was in a man's shoes for
like a week and saw the world from a
man's perspective film for a week i
think like
sure she'll cancel feminism herself
well when i first started when i first
started hearing this and i saw this in
the comments people will say well i i'm
more logical than most females like and
like and
by and large sure right like some
females are more logical than others but
we're chemically different every single
day and the week before our period i
don't care who the hell you are you are
illogical
we'd be acting crazy
and like we can't like men
will never understand how crazy we feel
the week before our period and like you
just get so mad over the stupidest
things and you know it's stupid but you
can't help it and we'll never we'll
never get it you'll never you'll never
get it
and that's that's the thing is like
girls want to say oh well i'm logical
i'm a lot more logical than some men
sure there's some beta ass guys you're
probably more logical then but by and
large men just make decisions better
than us and we're so indecisive it's so
hard for us to make a decision like part
of the reason i think this channel's
grown so fast is like i have my dad to
help me make decisions and i have a
manager that helps me make decisions
where like i think if i was just doing
it myself i would be
figuring out what camera i'm buying all
day where i can just say ish pick the
camera like
sudden super chats
super chess please
okay it's a camera
hashtag
hashtag
okay i'm gonna read actually speaking of
which i'm gonna read some super chats
okay guys for real we are trying to
raise money by the end of the month so
by the end of next month we can get
issue camera if you want to know
if you want to know what ish looks like
he could be anything put in the chat
what you think ish looks like
um yeah send some super chats okay um
lazy artist instead of getting issue
camera just put a mirror behind the gray
couch and we'll see his reflection
i love myself do you know the funny
thing you actually wouldn't because i
have a monitor that is blocking that
that's true we could put it in this gray
chair right here but i appreciate jess
with his smart comments
[Laughter]
she's so logical
i'm different okay um ultravoid hell no
just get your ass in the bathroom and
cry it out because when you open that
door you better be done and cleaned up
just tell them you ate something bad
energy
my dad couldn't die i just had some food
okay john smith my ex pushed me to talk
about my child abuse in the hands of my
mother to the point of crying guess who
got used as a weapon a month later never
cry
in front of a woman never do that bro
evil
the savvy ninja the proper amount of
crying in your woman is she is surprised
to see you cry also she could count on
one hand how many times you've cried in
the past year in front of her
marco beck jordan in the dominican
republic and the government don't
involve isn't involved in wedding and
marriage and look how many children they
have i actually have no idea how many
children they have um christian rennie
men will always
accept being the breadwinner but women
will never accept doing the same men
will marry a woman with no money women
won't john gq selective cooking is like
selective femininity i'll be feminine
for the right man i'll cook for the
right man
ian mack no guy wants to cheat and hurt
his woman cheating is a man he sneaks
out of his house to go and find some
happiness behind your back so your
feelings aren't hurt cheating is for you
it's not for me patrice o'neil
fresh fade i'd rather be with a six who
is submissive over a nine or a ten any
day alex lopez there's value in simply
appreciating a man marco beck jordan i
know how to know how to cook give peace
lift your man up and he will lift you up
mom bernie uh here is five of the third
of third world money it's almost one fun
dollar pearl has strong leg game can i
say that is that hashtag me too great
shout out oh gary
gary
gary grant please stop lying to women
there is only 10
there are only 10 of all women all races
are beautiful all the rest have to have
to have to depend on the makeup and put
on a facade uh marco beck jordan zoe
salada from colombia um
dragon stallion one zero zero one ish
the oompa loompa
let me know he's almost gonna get to the
door handle today i am
i've been working on my calves trying to
jump leg day
if you want to see the world's shortest
man send money for it
okay um wait hold on i want to read one
one or two more um it's a sad state of
affairs that crying is considered that
makes you weak this is where red pill
loses me if i cry and she wants to leave
good riddance i understand biological
predisposition but damn i'm a human too
look at what we're talking about bye and
never mind okay um gecko jesus single
mothers are valuable to single fathers
and vice versa
there is not a long line of childless
single women who want to become
overnight stepmothers ex f boy speaking
from experience i do think that people
with kids should just date each other
yeah
leave us out of that
um
okay yeah that's all of them what was
your question jess
so
the
um comment was saying that
uh
the guy the
girl made her boyfriend talk about his
trauma and cry from it and then she used
it as ammo
does there come a point where you can
talk about something and as soon as you
feel yourself getting emotional it's
like okay we're not going to talk about
this anymore or do you just not talk
about stuff like that with your woman
because
she may use it
i feel like he was just an emotional guy
yeah
i think he's just i feel like he's just
an emotional guy and maybe like
you know maybe he was beetle from the
beginning to get me like
because really and trudy if like if so
if you're telling i get if you're
telling a story of that abuse and that
and maybe it can bring you to tears
i understand but if you understand
female nature and it was what is saying
before and it like you know
understanding what female nature is
what's good for a woman versus what a
woman wants
to understand like she wants to hear the
story in it and whatnot tell her the
story
tell her the story there's no need to
cry about it
you're a grown ass man now
so
i
in conjunction with what you're saying i
had a situation where i told a partner
something that was
personal or like sensitive to myself and
it was used against me in an argument
and so i can relate to him how did she
use it against you in an argument i'm
just curious so she used it as
a reason as to why
certain situations were happening within
oh and the relationship so she was yeah
i have heard girls say that where you're
doing this because of that yes exactly
oh my god i've never healed from it so
that's why yeah oh my god because girls
will be like oh he's doing this because
of his childhood
and the men are like i told you that in
confidence
and now you're bringing it up as ammo
yes
and this and this in itself is what i
mean by
men not needing to be vulnerable to
their woman
and probably going to their
their boys their boys
or to seek counsel before bringing
topics that are sensitive because
and
i didn't even think of it as a malice
thing i just understood that men and
women are different men understand if
there's an argument between two men
there's a line i cannot cross
um
to ensure that world war iii doesn't
break out yeah women on the other hand
the break that looses every anything
goes is what it is like i think i think
it's i think i think there is a line
when it's women talking to women no
no
because a woman a woman talking to
another woman obviously if you cross
that line with another woman that that
other woman can punch you up
i think that women and women will fight
each other no gentlemen but when is
women talking to men that's when and the
sisterhood
and the sisterhood like i think women
naturally like
are nicer to other women not nicer
because it's like more of like
backhanded stuff you know what i mean
but i do think like
women are worse to men than we are to
women you know what is yet women have a
sharper tongue um than than guys do
so especially when you're opening up to
a i can't lie when you're opening up to
a woman you've got to make sure she's
the right type of woman to open up to
you because if not
no
i just think i just think
you shouldn't be opening up to a woman
about things that could really do damage
yeah
and like
and don't get me wrong i do
want to be have an open relationship
like communication wise communication
wise with a woman all right um however i
understand that there are certain things
that if a girl goes oh i want you to
open up to me i understand i don't need
to do that that's not a need in our
relationship that's a want
um
and it's interesting because i i have
like now that you say it like that i can
think of so many times i've heard girls
say to me like oh he does this because
of that
and i don't think a lot of times they
mean it in a way that's like malicious i
think they're just trying to diagnose
the problem but we're not we're not
doctors you know i mean like you're not
a therapist why are you doing this
i think a lot of women
do it like oh so-and-so is acting like
this because of xyz
and they don't take accountability for
what
they did in this situation as a whole
they'll say oh
he is acting grumpy or he's acting this
way doesn't talk to me because when he
was in a difficult situation when he was
younger he acted the same way and he
hasn't healed from that and it's just
like no did you say something to like
analyze yourself if you have no problem
in it then maybe it is but if you pissed
him off or put him in a difficult
situation where he didn't want to react
in a way that was going to be negative
then he won't talk to you i want to add
a caveat
it was used in an argument
not just a case where like you you
brought it up like he's probably doing
this because he's that's not an argument
that's diagnosing a problem that's
stating a
possible fact and probably a probable
fact as such but using it as ammo in an
argument
is one thing yeah and that's where there
is
like a no wonder you're like that
because like yes like this yeah that's
why
that's what i was going to say like i
think um girls do do um use it in a in a
malice sense because like and again it
doubles back to how emotional women are
when it comes to crossing lines with
guys in um in arguments once a girl's
heated there's no we double back there's
no barriers there's no lines they will
say whatever they feel at that given
moment to hurt you or to make you feel
less than just because they're angry so
if they're angry you also have to feel
angry and they don't care whatever and
if they have ammo if they have like ammo
and this ammo is personal they they know
it's going to touch a different type of
nerve that's going to make you feel the
type of way and if it does that's
mission accomplished to them
and i think it's also and i think it's
also to do with the fact that they know
that a guy wouldn't necessarily hit them
yeah you understand like because
as
a guy you can tell a guy something
personal and they still want crosstalk
even if they don't like you they still
won't cross that line and and come with
the verbal stuff and stuff like that
because they know that yo you say that
it's still about the next one yeah
100 do you understand but um
but like with with a goal it's a
different kind of it's a different kind
of thing because the dynamics
you're giving me as a guy the same
signals that if a guy was giving me
these signals it's a fight
so those same signals are blurring up in
my brain
but you're a woman so i can't really
react the way i'd react and that's why
that's why women do it they know that
they can get you with their words cut
down your character cut down whatever
but they know that you can't you can't
react you can't
hit me you can't do anything only thing
you can say is something to me but
that's not that's not australia yeah
that's not the
nature of a guy is to attack someone's
character but i think i think women men
have a natural inclination to protect
women mm-hmm
i just like i think
[Music]
and it could be someone you know someone
you don't know it's just like innate to
protect the woman that's why there's
that whole there's that saying where you
you want to cross an old lady like you
know you want to make it make sure she
crosses the streets you know probably
know what hold on old lady's bag so
which crosses the streets that is it's
that kind of protection that they want
to do for women and women abuse it yeah
i mean that's why you see situations
like the amber heard stuff come out i
mean because women know we like women
know they can get away with it
because a lot of times there's no
consequence because honestly i think men
are very forgiving like if you have a
problem with a woman men move on women
will never let the guy stop hearing
about it forever for all of kingdom come
and
so a lot of times like women don't face
consequences for bad behavior
it's true and it's partially the guy's
fault too to be honest because if more
women face consequences and more guys
said we're not going to deal with this
women would have to be better
because like attention is currency to
women yeah i think it was said on on a
podcast here like a couple sorry a
couple podcasts ago like they said if
something is given
like and there's no like like uh
consequences to whatever that is being
given it's gonna get abused
you understand and i think like the fact
that you know girls can say say say what
they want do what they want and there's
no consequences especially when it comes
to guys if it's against a guy or whatnot
like there's no consequences it starts
to get abused and whatnot and that's why
we come with situations like amber heard
and stuff like that and you know that
whole case was
exactly because because these policies
and this uh
believable woman and you know women are
always right or women are always telling
the truth or what not like it gets
abused and then you know you get
situations like that yeah and to even i
don't want to further add on to what
you're saying like that whole situation
even just illustrates how women know the
dynamics in society that they have um
because she was i um when i was watching
it she was all like oh i'm a i think 115
pound girl um
compared to however whatever the weight
was compared to johnny depp like they're
not gonna see it as are you me hitting
you is gonna really be a big thing but
at the end of the day the act is still
the act you hit a guy like
what would you naturally if another guy
even if the guy was 115 pounds like if
it was a guy the whole situation would
be different it would be it would be
more natural for him to um
for for an audience to expect or a guy
hits another guy retaliation retweet but
because he's a female now the whole
situation is different and she knew that
the fact that she's a woman who's a lot
more light-hearted and ex-wife said it
wouldn't be seen as it's that deep or is
that um it's that significant just
because he's a guy who's of a heavier
stature in xyz i always say equal rights
equal left if you're gonna hit a guy
expect to get hit
you don't if you if you went up
you could say it like if you if you went
up to dwayne the rock johnson and you
hit him and he decked you back nobody
would feel bad for you because he's
stronger than you
that's what girls do is they'll they'll
deck a guy and be surprised if he gets
he gets decked back and then they'll
arrest the man the audacity
like there are men there there was a guy
that died um a couple weeks ago because
like the girl was literally abusing him
with like a chair and all this stuff and
he he
i remember he like literally died of
brain damage oh it was good yeah like
girls
girls are um
like i mean they can they can do some
pretty shitty things they get away but
then again is the double standard in
this lifestyle and this in this life
that we live like it's just
it's just how it is because females are
because guys are known to to be the
protectors so it's just naturally it's
like oh it's it's it's it's look it's um
what's it called it's not really looked
at in the same light as if a guy wants
to hear a girl compared to a girl
hitting a guy because just because of
the roles that we play in society well
and then every time
you know what
is an interesting dynamic if you say she
hit me the first question is what did
you do yeah
and you know what's crazy is i i think
i've asked a guy that before before i
was red pill like because i
and i don't know why it's just kind of
like ingrained in society
i don't know yeah that's all about one
though but yeah
yeah but sometimes it's even instinctual
it's not even a yeah like even yeah guns
will go yeah what'd you what did you do
man yeah she hit you like what'd you do
it's like
and i think i think the more of these
cases come to the forefront we kind of
realize what's going on
but i just think naturally like men and
women have a natural inclination to
protect women yeah and i uh too but no
more [ __ ] these hoes
sorry no no you get to
vice versa it they will if a woman is in
an abusive
situation
most likely the parents or
from what i've seen the mother will be
like well what did you do if he's a high
value man they will um
what's the word i'm looking for they
will
not make a consequence but they will
oversee it if a high value man is
abusing i've seen it in two different
scenarios
yeah one was an old um
tyler perry movie where the daughter was
being abused by the man but he was high
volume men had money lived in a mansion
all this ex xyz and
then the mom was like what did you do
for him to be upset for him to get that
way like what did you do and then in
another scenario um it was about it was
pretty much the same thing but the
parents were
benefiting off of the high value men's
money his family's money as well and so
it wasn't just the wife the soon-to-be
wife that was benefiting it was a family
as well so the parents were like well
you're gonna have to deal with it let
them hit you up a little bit because we
can't we can't go back on it and so
it's i don't know i don't know if that's
really reality though that's like a
movie
because women can leave and take half
if they if they sign a prenup
even even a lot of prenups get thrown
out yeah a lot of prenup's getting
further
they're like ten thousand dollars
they're expensive
if someone has a pretty much ten
thousand for april a lot of prenups get
thrown out and obviously like she can
claim that she was under duress when you
know oh yeah that one she can claim that
she was under duress when he made her
sign it and what i was crying i'm not
saying it doesn't happen i just don't
think it happens i don't think that's a
major
thing because we live in such a
gynocentric social order where women are
at such an advantage when it comes to
marriage i think it probably would
happen more if we weren't
i do have a
a question for um
for you two for you three the men um
since you three come from different
um
words are hard right now different um
brilliance not upbringing different
backgrounds like cultural backgrounds
have you seen that in cultural
backgrounds where if a woman is with a
high value man and he
is abusive have you seen
yeah yeah i mean
like in african culture like
i think with uh well specific african
culture i can't speak for every african
culture but i think there are specific
you know
if if you get if you get married to a
rich man
yeah like you if you the daughter your
family is gonna do whatever that you
know do whatever you can to stay with
this man he's rich he's given us you
know 60 cows he's giving us you know
pleasure do you see it in the west too
in the west in a different light yes in
a different light yeah like in a
different light like they'll like it
will be different but it's hypergamy is
real in every culture i think hypergames
ruin every culture and i think if you're
if you're a female that gets with a rich
man no matter what culture you're from
like your family will make sure that you
try to stay with that guy
yeah i can't i agree with him like this
from my culture
more time even if the parents don't like
it
if he's if he's bringing in the cows and
the goats and he's giving you all the
the
the things that you need they're going
to be like oh just
just you know what just just take it and
just just firm it hold it and just carry
on i'm sure you or they'll even make it
the woman's problem clear you might be
doing something wrong instead do this
instead or do that instead just to hold
it down but i think it only goes to to
an extent dollar but the initial
response would be you either have to do
something different
or you i've affirmed it but if it's if
it's extenuous and it carries on gone
for i don't know whatever period of time
and it's like enough is enough then they
will try to pull you out the game with
him but if not you don't what you think
they just
so in
from i know in african culture if it
gets extenuous they're taking you to
marriage counseling with the pastor
okay no but i'm saying everything i'm
not or not but i'm saying no but this is
that's past extenuous that's when it's
reached to a point where it's like it's
getting out of hand i can't lie and i've
seen in my culture when it's gotten too
too much then they try to pull you out
but the initial thing is we're going to
try and make it work regardless like
even if he's hitting you whatever i
don't know what the situation may be
they're going to try and make it work
and you're you're doing something wrong
you've got to change something up so
that it can carry on is it possibly
because the alternative is her being on
the streets yeah the alternative
yeah it's not just that
in our culture it's status and that
moment where you've married off your
child to a high value person right
you as a family or their parents are
bragging into the next door neighbors
saying i raised a child that was able to
be a wife and marry a
marry up into that family we did that
and that's a cultural bragging right
that you always have i mean the moment
you can get into divorce
then it's like it brings shame upon the
family exactly
that's
my second scenario it was from an
african movie so i wanted to hear if it
was true or false that's what that's
what the the mother to uh the groom she
was like do not embarrass me do not
bring shame to my family pride is all
about fat it's all about family name in
it at the end of the day especially with
african culture it's all about your
family name and um
and if you're a woman you know and you
marry into a high value family you know
you in turn your family becomes high
evaluation yeah yeah yeah
because it's it's now associated with
the high value families and whatnot so
and um
and yeah that's so that's why it goes
with what you're saying like don't
embarrass the family kind of thing i
mean i think we should go back to that
don't embarrass the family i don't not
abuse right that's that's a different
situation but i'm all about bringing
back shame
i think we should bring it back i think
you should be ashamed of getting
divorced yeah i have a friend my friend
was divorced and she'll say that was a
failure that's embarrassing
you should be embarrassed
i think you wasted everyone's time
and now your kids might be in a single
parent home that's embarrassing
you think you you should be embarrassed
you should be embarrassed of dating
every rapper from kingdom come
you should be embarrassed of posting an
ass picture on the internet that needs
to be shaped you should be embarrassed
about an only fans let's bring back
shame and bring back embarrassment bring
back slut-shaming
that's what they don't want though yeah
because
every girl's sexually liberated you know
and they feel like
because they can show their skin to the
world that it's some sort of liberalism
or some sort of freedom
and it's like
like i don't understand the correlation
me personally you understand where it
comes from like you know if your clothes
comes off that's you being more free you
understand like at me personally i don't
understand the correlation
but
no i just said feminism just teaches
females we should bring back fat shaming
too
we can bring back we already have broke
shaming men have that they're saying for
being broke
yeah
like i don't want to date a bomb
[Laughter]
oh that's not like let's let's be
embarrassed of these things because if
you find the problem you can find a
solution it's true i saw i saw this
thing today i put this on my story i
don't know if y'all saw it oh fine fire
buy your story okay if you get follow my
instagram low-key
okay
so i met a guy yesterday who said we
have a civic duty to try to be as
beautiful as possible your body isn't
just your own everyone has to look at
you you harm others if you set a bad
example and benefit and even please them
if you set a good example like why do i
have to look at the roles
man and women let's be ashamed of this
i've been fat i've been overweight
i feel like i'm i'm still trying to get
in better shape let's be ashamed
be ashamed to be in the [ __ ]
being ashamed to be a broke let's change
it no is she not
if you have shame on what not you're
going to want to change the problem if
you're accepting shame and after you get
comfortable with it you're just going to
end up dwelling in whatever whatever and
then after you're going to be there
complaining but if there's shame like
you're gonna end up you're gonna end up
finding a solution and you end up making
progress and xyz like you end up coming
out of whatever um poor situation you're
in and youtube like it but if it's
looked on as like oh no it's okay you
can you can be broke or you can be fat
you can still it's like that was back to
people thinking you can have your cake
and eat it too is that what all of a
sudden
because you're overweight you still
expect to get the high-end guy or the
big macho guy or if you're broke you
still expect to get the um the the
best-looking females the next one said
like it doesn't make sense is that time
and even single mothers shame putting
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage
you should be ashamed there was a time
in church here where they actually used
to shame women that
had babies out of wedlock oh yeah take
them to the front yeah bring them to the
front say
obligation we gathered here today
this lady
decided that she wanted to have her and
her husband
wanted to have a child
outside the construct constraints of a
marriage
this is unacceptable these are the
consequences for their actions for the
next
year or so they won't be allowed to
participate in certain situations they
will always be able to come fellowship
blah blah blah but they won't allow
they're not allowed to lead they're not
allowed to be in positions of power and
when i was younger when it happened i
was like no that's terrible oh my gosh
but
i i now understand
why they did it and of course throughout
time it's now become oh why would you do
that to people blah blah it doesn't
happen anymore look what's happening
because because
because men have to face consequences if
a man's broke reality hits him quick
unless he's like chad or tyrone he still
might get girls but
but for the most part
reality hits hits men quick but women
we're shielded from our bad decisions
and it hurts us in the end because you
might say oh it's okay to be a single
mother dating's gonna be okay you'll
make it but i'm sorry dating is ten
times harder when you have a kid it's
not to say it's over completely but if
you realize it's a problem you can at
least work to be valuable to a guy in
other ways and figure out a solution but
we don't know the problems
yeah that was about the same if you
don't know the problem yeah find a
solution yeah
no that's right but i didn't know the
the shaming thing was was that literal
like them
but also also i want to say is that um
what's it called i don't think this
whole the generation that we're in
everything has become too sensitive and
that's why
we can't that's why things like shaman
and xyz has has been um deflated and you
can't progress like that but i'm like
what we need to i feel like what we need
to understand as society there are harsh
truths that we all need to accept no
doubt about that if we can if we end up
learning how to accept all these harsh
truths we were able to actually make the
necessary progress and the necessary
steps forwards or at least see the
results that we want to see
once we're able to deal and understand
and accept these harsh truths because
once you know something like you said
you know the problem you get the
solution but if you've accepted the
problem and i think there's no there's
no issue with the problem now it's like
again one in your cake and eat it too
like well how can you how can you like
what you want the reward and take no
reason
that's what women want they want they
want the reward of a husband even though
they're overweight they want the reward
of a husband even though they got kids
they want the reward of a husband even
though they slept with the whole
football team the laws of life doesn't
work like that
and women women would get a lot further
if they said i don't deserve this like i
don't deserve him
but
women but women feel like they're better
than guys that are better than them i
think i think women need to look at
marriage
as if you're
like the same way you would go for
a high-end job at a firm yeah
and the same way you would go for a
high-end job you're going to come
prepared you're going to make sure you
do your research you're going to make
sure that you're that you're prepared
for that job
you're qualified for that job you're
going to make sure that you're qualified
if it's a high-end firm anything like
that you have to come if you want to be
a wife you have to approach it as if
it's a high-end firm because it is a
hype like we was using savannah james uh
that james corporation that's a
corporation like if you think about that
lebron james and his name is a whole
corporation you understand and she's
almost like the vice president of that
corporation if you want to say in terms
of their family maybe not with these
businesses but in terms of like their
family name and whatnot
men and women both or the is the girl or
guy you're dating on brand exactly are
they on brand for you do they would they
represent you well in public with your
family
and i mean i think men are like i want
to say they they do this too where
they're with a 304 that they know they
could never wife and it's bad for their
brand
and sometimes there's problems that come
with this
and women it's the same thing they'll be
with an f boy that's going to embarrass
them and it's like and it's like when
you are going for like that high end job
they do background checks
they do background checks yes
so
if one when they're doing that
background check a high-end firm do you
think a man shouldn't do a background
check on you when you want to be his
wife and that's why that's really
interesting what girls need to
understand that yo
like when you're going for a wife you're
going for an actual position like it's
like a job jonathan it's not job it's
not you can't look down on it because
you know submissiveness is frowned upon
nowadays you understand but if you're
understanding you understand what goes
into it it's a real life job and you can
really and truly benefit in the long
term do you understand like beyond your
wildest dreams you get kids and
and
it's the most important job you'll ever
have being a wife and a mother yeah
what's more important than that
what your analogy i can't lie was was tt
tt also means 10 out of 10 is top tier
you get what i'm saying just yes you
didn't know but um but yeah it's like
because with that when it comes to
background checks if if you're going for
a high-end job with a long-term career
and they've done a background check on
you and after they've figured out that
you've done something that goes against
their grain you're not you're going to
be upset you didn't get the job but
you're not going to be mad at them
that they rejected you it didn't fit in
with the profile but when it comes when
the when that sort of situation is
translated into the
um relationships
is
what do you mean just because i'm this
you you're not gonna say oh like all of
a sudden like again like we're saying
earlier it's on the guy like it's a bad
thing that the guy has rejected you
because you have this baggage or you
have whatever whatever but it's like
when you flip the script to the job
thing you don't get you just get mad at
the situation but girls don't get mad at
the situation when it comes to the
relationship they get mad at the guy and
now is a whole issue but girls need to
approach it like it's a job you need to
understand you need to come prepared you
need to you need to make sure that the
shoe fits if if i'm if i'm the prince
and shannon armor not princess but if
i'm the prince and i'm trying to i want
you to be my cinderella you need to make
sure that the glass shoe fits if it
doesn't fit how it's you can't be my
cinderella
women don't even understand what the
qualifications are
we lie to each other about what the job
posting is and where it is
and then some simps lie to women about
what the qualifications are too
so
i'm gonna come with the cv next time
here you go here's my shoot see if it
fits no what's that what's on your cv
jess
yeah what's up what's on both of your
cvs
both of them you know oh my god
i have to think about it
i'm the table so there's no
i make some fire
drumsticks i can cook i can clean
i'm the table
this table right here this is meat
i just learned to make some fire drop
you all don't even know purple been
cooking it up in the kitchen i
understand these drumsticks i'm going to
make some after this show
i'm so excited
oh man
okay i'm going to have to think about
that
what's your what's your dish
a dish yeah you got a dish
um
i can cook a mean
uh salmon with brown rice and lemon
pepper asparagus i got some salmon
cooked for me tomorrow
you're not a man
want to be submissive we want to be
feminine
[Laughter]
you're the one who had breakfast hey yo
okay i'm gonna read some super chats
okay okay um let me refresh it real
quick guys guys just so you know i know
i've said this before i'm gonna say it
again let's get ish a camera you wanna
know who is the man behind the mic who's
the man the myth the legend the five
foot [ __ ]
come on we out here
do it for the short men no no he's
almost five foot let's not lie
he stands on his big toe
okay okay um
donations for a camera we would like to
get one on ish um you know the way it
works by the end of the month um
youtube pays you at the end of next
month for this month so we're trying to
get as much as we can in june so we can
get a camera for ish at the end of next
month while you're at it like the video
and sign up for our memberships for
exclusive behind the scenes content okay
so for our next super chat just human
i'm not saying that you need to be
crying like the notebook but if i can't
trust myself to be vulnerable why take
her serious long term don't don't cry in
fear of losing her nah son
not me to be fair the red pill ain't
about marriage what do you think about
that ish
i think you make a choice um on how you
want to
have your feelings like if you're a man
that is in a position of power where
like your leverage is so much so that if
you cry she's not going to leave you
because she's got way too much to lose
then you're in a position where
you can be emotionally emotionally
vulnerable i think most people or most
women will settle for the beta which
means a man that cries is already in a
position where if he cries he loses a
point and he's now in a position where
she could walk away or lose attraction
because there wasn't that much leverage
that he had from the start that's my
logic behind it i can be swayed it i can
learn but that's my thought process and
mindset upon it at this moment either of
you have thoughts about super chat
sorry say that again okay so i'm not
saying you need to be crying like the
notebook but if i can't trust myself to
be vulnerable why take her serious long
term don't cry in fear of losing her nah
son not to me to be fair red pill isn't
about marriage
i think um
i think
if you cry like she might not
necessarily
like you know
break up with you there and then because
you're crying there and then no that's
not what was saying she might accept it
she might accept it that day that month
that year to understand but you just
never know when too much is too much
with a girl so it's best to just leave
it alone to understand because you might
think yeah look i can cry this much and
she'll still accept me but then maybe
one day you cry a bit too much and then
that one day that you cried a bit too
much he saw you as a [ __ ] do you
understand and from and from then and
then from that day it's done it's done
that's true so it's like it's like the
best prevention is better than cure kind
of thing do you understand so you rather
prevent it and instead of crying to her
with problems
come to her with solutions from come to
her with yeah i had previous problems
these are what i had and these are the
solutions that that you know that i've
now come up with go cry to your boys
that's the that's who i can ever advise
that i'm not saying meant to be a
steward never cry in your life no that's
not what i'm saying i'm saying yes cry
but if you want to cry cry to your boys
cry to you
men
and man them that you trust and you
believe that they're not going to judge
you after you cry do you understand that
those are the only people that will look
at you cry and then they'll tell you out
call suck it up bro you'll be all right
do you understand they won't judge you
after that now is that a girl can use it
against you that's what i'm saying no i
agree with what he says i agree with
what he says
naturally
yeah and actually i just don't even be
crying so
not to feel like i don't have emotions i
got emotions but naturally i just don't
cry and even if i do it'll be
it'll be something with the men and the
female
yeah i've just been taught to be the
strong figure in it like it's just
natural to
to muscle to make sure that i got the
backbone for for everyone that's in my
situation and being my girl i got the
backbone for her she can be the one
that's that can be soft but you get me
you can't have two soft people inside
the relationship it doesn't work out
um so then the next one marco beck
jordan the women got loose from jail no
court date either
oh that's crazy the girl that killed the
guy oh she got she got loose from jail
no court date either
k popsicles um look up the different
types of love i forgot
one but we learned it in psychology
it was used as an in
it used arranged marriages as an ex i
think it's empty love marco beck jordan
i saved a stranger from knife rooms put
my sweatshirt and suddenly a woman with
a butcher knife middle of the city
everyone was watching
and somebody
and snapping nobody called for help i
called myself society's broken from
norway
um gum gum pistol did this girl really
use a tyler perry movie as a reference
bra
[Laughter]
yes yes i did
no they humble you in the comments
um boy type pearl's right equal rights
equal lefts if she swings on you simp
mode are timing people out for saying
the exact same thing pearl is saying
90 free toe pie
hey gorgeous oc guys can cry to their
girls it's like talking
it's just like talking to them though
you have to know how they feel in the
moment time of the day the place at the
place are they with their friends did
they eat just human i understand what
you're saying about the majority of my
issue with the red pill is the choice of
action after the data women are turned
off by emotional men don't cry after her
if i can't cry around you i'm not
marrying you i think i've read that one
or
no
my upbringing oh wait no there's more
okay um i'm 18 years old and when i'm
mad or an argument i will stop and think
logically before i say or do anything
because i know how my words can affect
people my upbringing has brought
has a part to do with it just seeing my
mom i'm the oldest of two other sisters
and the peacemaker in the house actually
my mom always told me if you're mad
about something to wait two days and if
you're still mad then you bring it up
and that's always my rule of thumb
because i don't ever want to say
anything i regret so i always like wait
two days and if i'm still angry that's
when like i talk
i can understand
um okay
debo4735 thank you jess for saying x y z
and not x y z
i don't get it
women will you will use all a man's
secrets to inflict her pain on him star
king jess is looking like a healthy meal
out this month thank you thank you
cheers
um something to watch um
yo straight from the bronx favorite
quote stick and stones will break my
bones but they'll always be something to
offend a feminist
dragon stool one zero zero one for ish's
step stool
i appreciate you man
make sure it's a big one
[Laughter]
i need that height
yeah he can't he needs a foot he can't
he can't grab
sometimes i'm yeah reaching for the
camera is tough you know
y'all should get them on the dinosaur
clips
let me just refresh it real quick so um
i have a question for the guys how many
if a girl's a 10 how
oh wait wait one more one more i'm sorry
okay john smith the lesson i learned
from exercise experience with my ex just
don't bring it up now i look at the
abuse as irrelevant to my current
situation but then women call me cold so
f me either way right
um okay so
how many points does a child bring a
woman down who's a 10
oh
what if she's a 10th yeah
yo you become like you become average
yeah you because yeah you become average
wait sorry in terms of smashing or like
long term like long term long term you
become average what's smashing becomes
you're here for
so a 10 with a child so let's let's say
who's your celebrity crush
lebron
james because you men just said the tens
become average as if we find tens every
day that's what i'm saying i really want
to hear this because me i'm thinking
maybe eight
maybe seven what celebrity catch go yeah
who's your celebrity crush um uh my
growing up one of them was lauren hill
not lauren hillary london
okay growing up my one was making good
okay let's let's do so both of those
with a kid
we pick in the five with no kids so like
average looking no kids a nice girl same
personality let's just say one has a kid
she's a 10. what long term yeah i want a
wife long term i'm getting i'm going
with average money yeah i'm going with
an average yeah
um so who's your celebrity crush
i try not to do that i try i don't have
one like i i could i could name
a female that i think is beautiful but i
don't have a celebrity crush because i
don't like too much
always
just think of who he likes growing up
because we all had one younger so think
back
also i have eaten it for the lauren hill
i forgot to say that
okay let's go
let's go rihanna i don't know let's go
okay rihanna that hasn't been rant
through
okay oh one that hasn't been run through
okay um
megan good yeah megan good was
definitely okay okay so that's megan
good
with a kid yeah versus average girl next
door
no kids
who you picking
yeah
for a wife i'm sorry like but if it's
put like in front of me
i genuinely i don't know
bro stop the character you will
definitely be i'm not we're not saying
that you won't beat me
we're not saying that when we won't beat
baby mothers of course
of course they don't discriminate
i'm just looking at from a standpoint of
like men look to qualify right so i'm
looking for when they're having sex no
one is just yeah
qualified qualified all
yeah just you not
forget the qualifications you
yeah
the average the average b
he's he he doesn't have no um children
or you're megan good he has a couple of
children even just the one even just the
one
just saying no no you're probably right
thank you
come one
looks fade that kid don't go away
yeah
how how how is he really going to be at
55 how hard is anyone and that's that me
personally my first kid has to be your
first kid that's how i see it
you understand that's how i can even
consider you as like a future wife you
understand like if if you've already had
that someone's already kind of like you
know what dogs do that when they when
they find a territory they usually piss
on that surgery
someone's already done that with you for
like and it's permanent to get me it's
kind of he's already kind of like pissed
on his territory and you know science
come out of it and it's like
and for me to get into that situation
now and i'm knowing the like like lions
don't do it forget me when lions go into
a new pride they kill all the cubs if
the if it's not theirs they kill all the
clubs or they tell them to just yeah or
they yeah or they exiled them jonathan
they killed all the little cops or the
eggs out of to get me and start their
own thing to get me obviously we're not
lions and animal wild animals but that's
it's kind of like it goes into how a man
thinks kind of thing to understand so
for me
yeah your first kid has to be my first
kid for me to even consider laughing you
bro well and you don't know if she views
you as the beta because that is a mating
strategy get the kids from the alpha
mary the beta yeah get the get the genes
from the one guy get the resources from
the other wow then you could find
yourself in a sexless marriage because
she's not really attracted to you
and i mean and you've heard so many
times where the baby mom is still
sleeping with the baby daddy even with
the new guy i'm saying yeah because
women release a hormone when they give
birth um that like bonds them to
the guy
yeah and so like that's a mating
strategy so like single mothers
females i mean that's why that's why
like a girl will sleep with one guy
immediately because she it's like the
jeans right so she she can't give up
that opportunity at good genes and like
that's why i say if a girl really likes
you she's not important [ __ ] yeah if
she's really into if those genes are
valuable to her she's she's not aborting
anything like that's why abortion is the
ultimate form of hypergamy
shout out roller to massey
don't even go to the lengths of taking
that out of the trash and putting in
themselves look at drake yeah yeah
and then and then who's the same with
brittany renner if that was an average
guy she's important yeah she's a part of
brittany she got pregnant by an nba
player
and she had videos talking about how to
trap a guy yeah i remember and so that's
what girls do is they'll get the kids
from the one guy and then marry the beta
and get the resources from the other but
she's not really attracted to the second
guy she just wants the resources girls
be plotting
no i said she got the jeans oh we should
go to the gym and then like she's
looking now she's with him now it's step
daddy season
yes she's been saying that yeah she's
looking for her stepdad
but she's got the basketball the
basketball guy was about the basketball
kid with the basketball guy
so now her kid her kid could potentially
be a basketball player because you know
their jeans
oh because
[Laughter]
but if a dude's not like if he doesn't
understand female nature what happens is
he'll the second guy will marry this the
girl think that you know she just made
some mistakes in her past
and she's genuinely attracted to him
but she's really not
um i don't think sierra is attracted to
her
because she if she was she would never
ever tweak on
twerk on the internet
we shouldn't be seeing sierra twerking
on the internet
yeah and like think about it her kid's
name future too so he's calling another
man's name in his house
hey my first boy will be called junior
[Laughter]
i can't laugh i'm gonna do that feature
come here
you're not my dad and that's the other
thing that's a common complaint i hear
from men is that they
they wife the single mom and they feel
like they're doing her a favor but he
doesn't give her she doesn't give him
the authority of the dads
so like that's why kevin samuels always
used to say like
would you give the stepdad the authority
to hit your kid
like to spank him or whatever and the
girls would say no
but how can you expect a man to come in
and do this job if you're not going to
give him the authority of a father when
he really has more responsibility than
the guy than the first guy because
most of the time women have primary
custody so this kid's going to deal with
the dad more than the other guy
see what i'm saying the holy but that's
that's why
i'd rather go with an average girl with
no um children there's a whole leap of
baggage that comes with even if the guy
isn't involved the child alone like
you're gonna have to do it for a second
you're gonna also have to deal with that
child somewhat slightly different
because it's not your son it's not your
daughter can i just say i had a lapse of
judgment there i want to apologize for
the to the chat to everyone on live that
i i even
questioned
questioned taking a person with a child
after all this red pilling i apologize
after lapse of judgment all of the red
pilling we've been doing here hey look
it takes a man to admit
i was doing a live the other day and i
was talking about amber heard and i said
in the chat smash your pass there were
so many guys putting smash
what is wrong with y'all she chopped off
a man's finger
i do
you want it you want to smash a girl
that chopped off another dude's finger
logically speaking there's no but if
i
no i'mma be so realistic if if the heat
of the situation's in the heat of the
situation things are happening
i'ma be so wrong if the heat or the
situations are in well
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying but i'm trying
to say
realistically not realistic you have to
be so rude as a guy don't be because i'm
not even gonna lie like you've gotta be
guys being guys if they hear the
situations and they hear the situation
things are happening however it's called
dick control
you got a lot of guys yeah i'm all for
i'm all forgiving y'all like okay
i'm all for
go ahead you know if you got the options
go ahead
do what you're going to do right
but like
isn't there some hoes that are too crazy
to screw no but because they come with
these problems that's before you get
into it i'm just trying to say that's
before you told you we've told you we've
told you what she's on behalf no but i
wouldn't go towards it though that's
what i'm saying i wouldn't go towards it
but i'm just saying what about why are
you bringing this up no no no no no
because there's
there's a part of you that knows that
crazy girls give the best time
[Laughter]
why are you laughing
why are you laughing
he's trying to put me in the corner
you put your own self in the corner who
are you thinking about nobody
in the corner
it's not even it's not even like that
just if she walks into the room i say yo
let's go with tv i'm not gonna do that
i'm sensible what it's like i was just
trying to say if i was in the situation
where somewhere yeah i don't know how
the situation occurred
but if it occurred
and yo hormones are just flying left
right and i said oh and everyone's just
yeah
yeah things could happen well he'll come
back to his senses after the next
it's not post not i mean i mean the post
not clarity is a real thing but
i do have it's a real thing
me i'm running away no this is what i'm
trying to say i'm trying to say if the
situation just you're in there but prior
i'm not gonna be i'm going to put myself
in a bad situation and yeah and then
just
nah that's that's just ridiculous like
you you're just asking for you can't
complain and suddenly left goals just be
like if something left happens you can't
complain inside left hand you put
yourself in there see [ __ ] on johnny
that's bad
yeah
yeah i'm not gonna say what
cause i
i have a question to rebuttal off what
pearl asked you guys earlier about the
baby mama or the um
the average girl
say the the ten
this was the first guy she ever slept
with and got pregnant this is she got
one body huh but she has one body count
and but she has a kid
but the average girl has
more than five more than five
i'm picking the average goal picking the
average girl 100 i'm picking an average
girl picking an average girl
that kid
is the
is
it's the trump card that's it
when in top trump's when you're playing
top trump's that's the trump card that
kid
that's in space because that's someone
else's seed
that you would have to raise and you
don't know her mating strategy
is the same
thing
do you know what it is it's the body
count part that i'm thinking about and
over but over a kid
that's that's something different but a
body count suggests is that she's not
going to stay with you anyway but the
kid suggested that there's a man that
will always be there physically and and
she just said as well sometimes they go
back to the baby father and still beat
them
what
the less of two evils is being with the
average girl yeah
and i'm not to say like oh like um baby
moms are
what's it called like they're just
they're trash or bottom barrel but it's
like if you no because in other words
that's how i was being paid out i'm a
but it's like so what are you saying
you've been trying no no it's like gee
you're not gonna be just naturally
speaking
oh this is
just but naturally speaking you're not
going to be you're not going to be the
first pick and you have to it's a harsh
truth to deal with you're not it's the
same way even if you're even if you have
a child you're not going to go for the
broke guy first you're going to want to
go for a guy who's going to be able to
hold you down as well as your child it's
just it's as simple as that it's a harsh
truth that you're going to have to come
to terms with like you're not going to
be first pick accept that and move
forward once you're able to accept that
then things will be a lot easier for you
but you can't complain when you're
getting all these other different type
of guys because you have a child like is
is just a harsh reality well and you and
it's a man you have to pay for it get
what i'm saying so not only do you have
to deal with the high risk but you also
it comes it hurts your wallet
because who's paying for that who's
feeding that kid
and on top of that you don't have no
authority as you said like you can't
smack him if he's chatting yeah
and and guys and boys usually learn
through discipline obviously
like we work within we're in a
generation now where a lot of guys are
very sensitive and you know the the
notion is being pushed oh yo don't don't
hit your kids
i believe don't hit female kids do you
understand i believe that that don't hit
like don't hit your daughters do you
understand like if you've got a door you
know make sure you don't hear about boys
boys you have to smack them up so like
so it can teach discipline them i
personally think if i you're a father
and you have a son
you have to discipline him like you have
to discipline him if he's doing
something wrong like i think you can
discipline women verbally if you've got
like if your father you've got a
daughter you can discipline her verbally
but i think with sun is with sons it's
kind of different because sons like boys
when they grow up they that reality will
slap them in their face whether they
like it or not do you understand girls
can some kind of get away with it do you
understand if you're where if your son
grows up and he does some some fat [ __ ]
he can end up in joel do you understand
and that that joel is worse than it's
worse for him it's better for him to be
disciplined when he was young so he
doesn't make those choices later on then
him not being disciplined when he was
young and then when he's older the
government's the one that's disciplining
him to understand so me personally i
think when it comes to fathers and sons
i think fathers should be able to smack
up their their kid if the if the boy is
moving mad
yeah no i i think that if you're going
to take on the responsibility of a child
like you should be able to treat it like
it's your own child and you should be
able to adopt it if you want to
because the other thing is if it doesn't
work out and you put 10 years into the
kid you have no you have no legal rights
to that child
so you could raise a kid for 10 years
and it doesn't work out with the baby
mom and you have no rights
you know that would hurt me
though yes you fall in love with the kid
and then now you have no right to the
kid
so it's just high risk altogether and
that even doubles back to the baggage of
just having an extra child that's not
even yours like you can't you can't talk
um you can't touch the kid and and even
for and even if you do touch the kid
then
even if the mom says you can't touch the
kid say that that doesn't like that now
you're gonna now you're gonna have a
whole pallava with the dead but it's
only natural for you to touch the kid
because he the child has to be
disciplined that's the only way things
can i'm not gonna say that's the only
way but that's one i would say is one of
the ways for things to work out you let
a child run loose and feel like there's
no sense of discipline he's gonna run a
mock of you and then after there's gonna
be no respect in the household and
that's just gonna cause all problems now
you touch the kid the father's gonna
come involved and now you have problems
with the father if he doesn't like what
you're doing to the cow and to the child
i mean and now that's a whole new proper
lava that can easily be avoided if you
didn't go with a baby mom and even if
you do go with the baby mom accept all
of that that comes with it if you don't
accept it again you're going to end up
with problems that you're not going to
be that you're not going to be able to
face because you didn't accept it so
just one of them was there like
people just need to know like people
just need to know what goes into every
single choice
just know the pros and know the content
that
like if if know the problems of know the
pros of being with a girl that belongs
to the streets know the concept do you
understand know the pros of being with a
girl that knows how to be a wife know
the pros of it know the pros the cause
of being with a baby mother now once i
want and that goes for men and women
once you know the pros and cons for
every situation you then
that make her you know a
sensible choice at the end at the end of
it
yeah
well i think this was a fun show guys um
i'm gonna read the last couple of super
chats and then you guys can give your
final thoughts and just tell the people
where to find you so i'm going to do
that really quick
um okay guys um
try i really was hoping to get to 142k
subs so we're at 141 933
and there's over a thousand people in
the chat and i know not all of you are
subscribed so get us to 142 by the end
of this stream if you can
also like the video it's super important
for the algorithm so
um
youtube has this thing where it if you
have a thousand people on the live it
does it best if half of them liked it so
if you guys could like the video while
you're at it a like is free
um and also sign up for our memberships
because you get some exclusive
behind-the-scenes content that includes
coffee thoughts where i give my like
shower thoughts basically for the day
and some vlogs that we have and we're
making a discord so if you want to be a
part of our discord sign up for our
memberships
okay so the
i'm going to read the last super chat so
um actually i'm gonna refresh it real
quick cause i think there's one that i
just saw
um sorry guys one second
okay
um cenor stinks
the queen of the whales is a high value
single mom
black is panther discipline is
misogyny um black is panther the way the
man she felt worthy of giving her womb
to was her first choice you will never
be her number one it will always either
be the baby daddy or the kid first
dragon stallion1001 next movie on
lifetime channel guy on the couch is
staring at the burning bed 2 starring
amber heard
[Laughter]
um robert um great content your guests
tend to be questionable
um jacob thought my sister recently told
me that she made her feminine husband
accidentally cry she has never dated
another guy and they've been together
since middle school they also got
married in a mormon temple marco beck
jordan he will become a two zo solata
um do dominican celebrity actress uh
marco beck jordan i got a high value
guilf one time um
john smith the lesson i learned from
experience with my ex don't bring it up
now i just look at my abuse as
irrelevant to my current situation
either way the women call me cold so off
me either way
okay so why don't you guys go around
any final thoughts and tell the people
where they can find you
um final thoughts um
it's interesting to
just hear men's perspective on like what
they care about when it comes to women
what they don't care about and how they
operate
in
just relationships as a whole i think
women really need to hear it but some of
them
won't listen because
it's a harsh reality and a harsh truth
and if they're not ready to accept it
then
they're going to be like oh no i don't
want to listen to it so i say women
should listen
and understand
men um that's my final thoughts
and you can find me
on instagram at it's dot ya dot girl
underscore jess
and then you can find me on youtube
edges it's your girl jess i would have a
different name but everything was taken
so
if you come up with a new one dm me
um my final thoughts on the mail
is that
in today's society we just need to
accept things for what they are and not
try to have our cake and here too
um literally if you go for what you want
know what comes with it and come to
terms with it
and i'm i'm telling you once you come to
terms with it there will be more a lot
more peace and a lot less stress um
yeah and just guys play your parts
females play your parts and and yeah um
you can find me at um instagram at
teoliny
um that's t-a-y-o-l-i t-a-y-o-l-i-n-i
not as um difficult
just over here you feel what i'm saying
yeah um yeah i make music so i'll check
out if you want to like if you like good
music but but yeah
sweet um
my last thoughts uh
yeah probably just going off the same
like know the pros or cons to every
situation that you put yourself in
trying to say if you want to be a wife
know what it takes to be a wife
if you want to be a husband know what it
takes to be a husband
if you're for the streets then you're
for the streets to understand and uh
just know the pros and cons in every
situation that you're in and
you know you'll know how to lift
yourself out if you don't want to be in
that situation
um
you can catch me on instagram p
silver dot o hg that's p s i l v a dot o
h g
and on youtube silver's way
um
yeah i make music as well so check me
out let's see one more thing yeah go
ahead um
guys
get that like and get that subscribe and
they're trying to touch 42. yeah they in
a long way away come on guys people just
yeah one click a day we need we need 30
more subscribers
42. that's the magic number i'm sorry
guys
oh yeah just uh just uh they say a like
a day puts all your stress away so if
you're stressed you just press that like
button you're going to be free as a bird
so you say what i'm saying just like and
subscribe when you're all good money
so yeah guys get the liking and
subscribing and just get that first
subscribers up
okay there's one or two super chats come
on guys there's a thousand of you in
here i know 30 of you can subscribe i
know 30 of you can subscribe while i
read these okay marco beck jordan i
found out on a children's photo of them
kevin smith be excellent to each other
everyone robert um big difference
between gentlemen and gentle men these
guys yikes
wow
sorry y'all i'm not a gentleman i'm not
going to claim it
y'all 89.85 come on come on y'all 15
more subs 15 more subs okay guys
i know we're so close
okay i'm gonna refresh it one more time
see if there's any more come on let's
see let's see
uh we appreciate everybody that has
subscribed today and since the time we
started and also liked today's video
appreciate you all thank you so much for
everything you've done we really do
appreciate everything 141 987 y'all we
are so close we are so close
three away
is this streaming on
your platforms as well yeah it's
streaming on twitch and facebook right
did it work streaming on twitch and fate
we'll talk later okay it might not have
worked we've been having an issue 91
come on
come on come on come on come on 141
991 you think we wait till we hit it you
think we wait till we hit it
hit that subscribe button unsubscribed
[Laughter]
come on come on
come on give us the subscribers also
also also guys seriously our memberships
is going to be very cool we're going to
have a discord community what else are
we doing with our memberships jess we're
going to have some behind the scenes
contents if you want to get to know
ishmore myself more pearl or this the
team more you'll be able to
see what we do behind the scenes there's
going to be merge there's going to be
exclusive things for members only and so
people who aren't members if you see
these members walking around with some
just pearly things a pregame merch and
you're like where'd you get that from i
got to become a member
you want equal rights equal left
you want to save the whales on a t-shirt
no leave sorry leave the whale sorry
leave them don't leave the wheel if you
want to
that's what's up leave
thank you
um for real though jess is in charge of
memberships and you know she she is
getting a decent chunk of the
memberships so if you want to you know
fund jess too please
or you just want to fund me peter pier
okay guys don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for real thank you for
getting us to 142. bring that
notification bell like the video on your
way out this was a great show we will
talk to you next time
and that's a wrap yeah